Dude, these people are psychotic.
>> Look at this dude.
>> Like there's I'm sorry. There's like insane aura farming
going on that I can't deny no matter how much I think this is
psychopathic. Okay, >> who's this guy is? Anyway, it's
like I don't get
what how did I not hear about this the second it happened. This
is awesome. Hold on. We're not even remotely close to done. There's
a bunch of the There's a bunch of other ones as well. Critical
Queman voice crack. Kenny, you ready for a critical voice crack?
>> Yeah, I'm ready. I play it.
>> I don't even know what this is. I don't even know what
this is.
Yes. That's every day. >> Success is
I think Ryan wants me. Um, sorry, I'm getting DMs. I think Ry
wanted me to look at this Tommy C thing. Let me see here. They
get everything wrong.
This really only 15 minutes. >> Let's go early. >> Ry
told me there's a 15-minute rant here and then didn't link me
the time stamp to the rant. Give me a second. Jay, it's got to
be here at the end, right? I >> don't know. Jay-Z talks
to anybody. They texted him. >> So do I. Tommy.
>> Ry, if you're watching right after the intro music.
Oh, okay.
Wasn't going to rant about this. Okay. Let's take a look. Let's
take a look. Let's take a look. Dude, I don't even I don't know
anything about this guy. I feel it sucks reacting to him because
I know nothing about him. I know I don't know what to say back
to him. I like I I literally don't know anything. He talks about
me and Queen a lot cuz I think I think people in Queen's community
with them a little bit. They get everything wrong.
They get everything wrong
again.
They get everything wrong again.
Eastern Standard 3:25.
The conversation with the cop already happened August
I can't re I cannot really uh Oh. Oh. Uh this is by the way,
this has got to be proof that Willie is consulting this uh group
chat right about this. Tommy C is showing his video showing that
he's reading his Discord and he is talking to Willie. I knew
Willie couldn't make any of these decisions on his own. I knew
it. I knew it. Oh, I'm always right. I'm never wrong. I'm always
correct. I'm always correct. Willie, Willie, I guarantee you
you ever get those logs leaked. It's Nicholas Yorio just driving
be like, "Willy, you got to report this. Willie, I'm telling
you right now, you got to report this. If this ever comes out,
if these logs ever come out and you didn't report this, you're
going to be [__] You have to report it now." >> I
can't elaborate on this at all.
>> I'm not sure about what This is going to be a terrible
podcast. >> God damn it, Tommy.
>> [__] sake,
>> dude. I wonder if counter points. Can we get counter
points to denounce Willie Mac for backstabbing Destiny for clout?
That's a great point, Kilo. I need counterpoints to come out
and actually explain to Willie how he just backstabbed Destiny
for clout and it's absolutely disgusting. It was leaked that
Dioro was helping Willie and that Dioro solicited Aiden Underground
to build a bridge with Queenman. All this came out today. I can
provide a clip. I feel like that's not necessarily true, but
go ahead.
>> Is Is there still a boat in the water or is it sunk?
I can't I can't do no I can't say a thing. >> Tough but
Perry leaking the Doro. Why to Aiden about Queen? Oh well we
heard this already. Or wait did I hear this in private? I might
have heard this in private. I might have heard this in private
speaking for Dior. This >> What does this have to do with
Dior? >> Cuz you had those DMs that Dior was sending you
about how he was mad at Freeman and you didn't want me to talk
about it. >> Did you look through my computer?
>> No. That was a group chat. That was a that was a VC
after a stream one day. I'm almost positive that this is a VC
after stream one day and Perry was there. I'm almost positive
that this happened. Maybe maybe I'm misremembering, but it was
like >> maybe I'm misremembering >> your DMs. It
was like
lying about >> What the is wrong with you? >> I'm
pretty sure Perry is joking here. Is memeing. I'm pretty sure
Perry's just memeing cuz we were all in a a chat like after the
stream at some point cuz I remember
Hold on. I remember cuz I was joking about like, "Hey, play the
recording." Oh, it was a Yeah, I I was joking about recording
him saying some of these things. >> Your bro,
>> I was just bringing it up because you're saying that
I'm not allowed to bring up private stuff like that. But if you
wanted to bring it up, >> you wait, backtrack. When I was
out of this room, you went through my computer. >> No,
I'm saying Perry's joking about reading the chats,
about reading his Discord logs. He's not joking about this thing
happening,
but I'm positive that we I'm positive that this was in a VC.
We talked about this. >> They're just a nick DM. The first
>> There's no way he actually went through his nick DMs.
Is there There's no way that Perry went through Was it on stream
cuz I don't believe it. I don't believe it. I don't believe it.
If he did, Perry is insanely antisocial. What's up, Aiden? You
there with Perry still?
>> Dude, are you dumb? Yeah, >> you're so lost right
now. You're so He >> This is not a troll. He did actually
read my DMs. I stepped out. >> But you understand you told
this to all of us, right? You understand you told us about this
>> about It happened The DM he read happened a day ago.
>> Oh, well then Darl has been complaining about Queen
for a long time.
>> Okay. Um,
but anyways,
I stepped out for like two minutes to do my intro screen and
then I see him messing my laptop
and I come back in and I'm like, what are you doing? He's like,
I was looking at our DMs. You never respond. For some reason,
I bought that and then we kept going and I realized he when he
brought that up, he actually just went through mine. >> There's
no way. Is there really
that's like >> Yes. Yes. Nick me. >> That's like
some actual uh I feel like I feel like Perry would actually like
you in real life if he did that's like a crazy thing to do the
first time you meet somebody.
>> Holy [__] >> You're telling me. You're
telling me. It's like how could you not >> I'm empathizing
with you. Okay. That's a crazy thing to do.
>> Yeah. And someone's like how could you not have known?
And it's like what do you mean how could I not have known? He's
just like a troll online. Like I I wasn't expecting him to like
actually do
>> I had some crazy to do the first time you meet somebody.
>> But to be honest, I'm not really mad at him. Like I
should have known. Like it's just who he is. I should just watch
my [__] better. >> You are completely mind
if you just let that go. But it's fine.
>> Fair enough.
That's like a massive breach of trust if that's how that went
down.
I'm just saying people are saying, "Oh, everyone got really mad."
That's crazy.
>> What the is Why would you ever think that's an okay
thing to do out of >> I was just It's funny, man. >> That's
like an incredibly psychopathic thing to do. I'm sorry. That's
like total psychopathy right there. That is obviously total psychopathy.
I sent you a time stamp if you want to be uh if you want more
of Aiden mad. Well, why is this Queenman's stream? Wouldn't there
be their stream? >> But I'll own that. I'm embarrassing,
>> So, you're just going Okay, sure, man. But you are sweeping
for Dioro. This >> what does this have to do with Dior?
>> Cuz you had those DMs that Dioro was sending you about
how he was mad and he didn't want to talk about >> Did
you look through my [__]
>> There we go. There we go. >> You are sweeping
for Dorio. >> What does have you had those DMs that was
sending you about how he was mad and he didn't want to talk about
Did you look through my [__] computer? That's all
you hear. I was going to say
it's actually psychopathic. I'm sorry. That's totally psychopathic.
It's funny as Okay, I will give it to you. It's funny as
holy [__] That's a psychopathic thing to do,
dude. Paran. Holy. Well, he didn't tell him anything. He didn't
tell him anything at all, did he? He just went on his computer.
He went on his computer and found the DMs. Oh my god. Yeah. Oh
god, it's Kaku. Okay.
Jesus Christ,
>> So Dioro's crying in Aiden's DMs. Jesus. You know what
I don't do? You know what I don't do? I don't go to Aiden and
say, you know, I'm really upset with Yorio right mad at Dior
right now. You know what I say to Aiden? I say, "Yo, Yoro. He's
lying about X." And I show the thing that he was wrong or lying
about. >> Uh, that sounds like Queen
very well criticisms that weren't based on his feelings of being
an estrogenic loser. >> Those DMs that Yorio was sending
you about how he was mad at Queenman and he didn't want to talk
about. >> Did you look through my [__] >> I
did. I saw your your DMs. There was lying about >> What
the is wrong with you, bro? I'm just bringing this up because
you're saying that I'm not allowed to bring a private sh
wait backtrack. When I was out of this room, you went through
my >> Okay, I'm just I'm just going to say it. I have uh
I do have a private call. The exact one I was thinking about
where I I'm pretty sure Pepsi was there and uh Aiden talked about
some along these exact same lines.
So,
I'm just saying Peter >> just
the first thing I was
>> brilliant. Brilliant. Yeah, I just went to I just looked
at like the most sensitive the most sensitive part, you know,
the one that I could [__] over with in public the
most,
dude. So good. So awesome. >> The [__] Why
would you ever think that's an okay thing to do? >> Aiden's
just performatively getting upset because uh actually there's
his DMs with like a 13-year-old
Italian boy that Perry just totally missed. Okay, cuz Perry was
too obsessed with clout. Perry could have done an actual investigation,
found the child that Aiden was grooming, but instead Perry had
to go for the Nick Dioro DMs. It's up to >> you. I was
just That's funny.
>> This guy's such a menace, man. He's such a menace. >> Aiden.
Holy
not doing well right now. Aiden is not doing well.
H
That's [__] up.
I I can't believe Barry did that to him. I can't believe Barry
did that to him. That's like >> Oh, what an absolute Nick
was Can I get the time stamp for their stream so I can see the
Nick chat messages, please? I need the Nick chat messages. Or
do I just go find this myself? I just go find this myself. Aiden
underground, give me this. Give me this right now. 3 hours
>> Well, I didn't know they were supposed to be a survivor
at the time. >> But wait, but then but then they informed
you midway through that they were. And did you not then go back
on >> No. Well, I did go back to explain to me what they
were doing in the waiting room, but not to embarrass them. >> No,
it was screaming asked to me. I >> But you knew it was
wrong with you. >> I mean, maybe it was wrong of me to
do, but I would do this again. I would do this again. But yeah,
obviously it was. You're saying that I'm not allowed to bring
up private stuff like that, but if you wanted to bring it up.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Backtrack. When I was out of this
room, you went through my >> Just an ickium. >> The
first thing I do is deal. >> What the [__]
is Why would you Everything that's an okay thing to do out of
curiosity. >> Sorry. All we need is this. Okay. The >> I
buy alcohol. Okay. I show you [__] kindness. And
what do you do? I leave the room for 2 seconds and you're on
my computer looking through my DMs. >> Well, listen. I
Yeah. Yeah. >> What the [__] is wrong with
you? >> I mean, maybe it was wrong of me to do, but I would
do it again. Maybe it was wrong of me to do it again. >> Uh,
let me Let's check those DMs. >> Wait, no. Why is he still
reading the DMs? How is he still reading the DMs? Aiden, stop
him. Aiden, stop him now. Aiden, you've got to stop him from
reading these DMs. Do not let Nick be humiliated like this. Aiden,
what are you doing? No, no, wait. Hold on. Put your [__]
over there, bro. Hands up.
>> I go in, I see you going through my [__]
I say, "What the fuck?" And I didn't think I thought you were
joking around with me. Like, I'm just looking at our DMs. You
don't DM me back. >> That was true. That was treated daily.
>> So, you lied to me, man. It's really annoying. Oh, no.
I did lie to you. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, absolutely.
It's all over the
by the way. Listen to me. Listen to me. Listen to me. I trusted
you with my computer in the room. >> I leave for two. >> Check
DM. Hold on. Okay. That's [__] Why would you do this?
Am I really going to do this to another guy? Am I really going
to show the Perry side profile right now?
Dude, that's crazy.
that's [__] up. Dude,
I can't throw the first stone on having a bit of a gut. Okay,
I can't throw the first stone on this. Perry's funny. Perry's
funny. Okay,
that's all I know. After I listen to Perry describe Connor as
a powder keg and describe the consequences of Connor's emotional
stoicism, okay, his failed attempts at stoicism, I really can't
hate this guy, okay? I can't hate him even after leaking those
Well, I especially can't hate him after leaking those DMs. That's
funny as [__] But
I don't think I could trust this guy. He's uh he's robotnik coded
right now. You got to
He's evil. Okay. He's robotnik coded. What did you expect,
Aiden? What did you expect? >> And you take that trust
and you violate
>> And you think that's like a normal thing to do? >> Um
I say it's I think it's I I don't think it's a good thing to
do. I feel like I said it. You're literally like Denims when
she like took that guy back to
the way. >> But that's you. Yeah, dude. Aiden is
Aiden. Oh, hold on. Well, yeah, just lie and say everyone is
DG affiliated media to pander to the few people who fill your
streams. Lol.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. I've I've always corrected on Nicholas,
by the way. Not that Nicholas will care or anybody cares about
me being intellectually honest here, okay? Nobody gives a about
this. All right? even if they pretend to. But I always say that
I don't think Nicholas is DG affiliated at all. I think he I
think he might have some idea that Willie understands that his
audience is there, but I don't think Nick is DG affiliated at
all. >> No, I was jumping in cuz then you s I saw you were
looking and you saw him, so I went back to my thing and I lied
about I was looking at games. So that's all I
>> You're like a crazy person, dude. I act as a psycho
into my room. >> But yeah, you guys just lie and say everyone's
DJ affiliates in media to pander to the few people who fill your
stream. So now he's calling it no,
>> dude. Uh, I got to I can't lie. Okay, I think this is
one of the most psychopathic things I've ever seen that Perry
is like an actual fullyfledged psychopath, but it's hard to deny
that he's orming right now. Okay, he's oring so hard. He literally
just leaked these DMs, humiliated Nicholas, kind of humiliated
Aiden, and is reading out Nicholas's chats and like laughing
at him to his face.
Like there's I'm sorry. There's like insane aura farming going
on that I can't deny no matter how much I think this is psychopathic.
Okay. >> What the [__] is this? This nick guy
is anyway. It's like >> I don't give a [__]
about >> what? How did I not hear about this the second
it happened? This is [__] awesome. This is so [__]
awesome. >> You went through my computer while I was out
of the room. >> Yeah, I did. >> [__]
it. Dory Mac Gon. I walked out of this room and you went through
my >> No, I did. Yeah, I did. >> How am I supposed
to move on from that? I don't know, man. Anyways, you want to
edit here?
>> Aiden's community is sending me uh Aiden's Clippers
are sending me stuff. It's like not good. Okay, these guys are
mad. Perry's in trouble. Okay, these these Aiden Clippers are
mad. They're making they're making videos calling them fat. Okay,
this is not going to be good. Perry, you don't know. You just
shook the hornets's nest, my friend. You just touched the hornets's
nest. Get ready. It's coming for you. Is this the hotel before?
Is this before the hotel is set on fire? Had to be after because
it was today. That's not a burned down
>> Keep going. I mean, I don't >> I got to I got
to back it up a little bit. Wait, I don't know. This is way better
content than like anything else that's going on today. This is
amazing. You can't call funny people fat and feel safe.
That's true. That is true. >> DG. I walked out of this
room and you went through my computer. >> No, I did. Yeah.
>> How am I supposed to move on from that? >> I don't
know about you. >> No, we can keep we can keep going. I
mean, I don't like there's nothing I can do about it now. Dude,
these people are
Why am I being sent the host of search right now,
dude? This is crazy. Hold on. We're not even remotely close to
done. There's a bunch of the There's a bunch of other ones as
well. There's this guy. Dude, I'm never I'm never face revealing
for these community the these communities. Dude, this is crazy.
These people are going insane.
All of these people are going insane at the same time. I don't
even know what this is. I don't even know what this is. I don't
even know what's going on here. What the [__] is
happening?
Oh, we're uh Oh, hold on. What are we We're uh five subs. Five
subs away from another hour on the stream, guys. Five subs away.
Five subs away. I've not been chilling. Well, I'm not going to
end before this stream segment anyway. So, if you guys wanted
to get away without adding more time, you probably could right
now. Okay, this is very funny. Sorry, I have more I have more
clips here. More clips. I don't know what this is.
Dude, Perry does not look as big as he might be via his face.
Like he has a very misleading like his face is not
his face doesn't look anywhere near as heavy as his uh as his
tummy might indicate. Like when I just see his face on stream,
he's got like a skinnier face
somehow. I don't know what this is. Jesus. And it's just the
side profile as he walks by. I give very props for the all white
outfit he rocked to the stream though. Okay, all white. That
was a bold choice. Didn't do any black to to smooth himself down
at all. He just went all white. He just went all in all white.
No way. No way. When I DM someone, I trust him to keep our conversation
private and safe from uninvited eyes. What happened today was
in no way funny. I know I usually come off chill, but when I'm
mad, I'm mad. And today I'm mad. Aiden, you [__]
up. Aiden, you [__] up. Aiden, listen.
I've actually totally come down from the moral effing I was doing
for two seconds when Aiden was here. Uh, Aiden, you [__]
up. Okay, Aiden, you let a guy in and you should have known who
he was. Okay, this guy's a total psycho. You should have known
he's a total psycho. He just spent like two hours on stream calling
counterpoints a like two days ago. Okay, you should have known
exactly what Perry was. You let him onto your stream. You let
him into your room. You gave him alcohol. And you listen, you
sow the wind. You reap the whirlwind as uh the counterpoints
chatter said. Okay. Sew the wind. Reap the whirlwind. You gave
Perry alcohol. Now observe what happens when you leave him alone
with your computer. Okay. It's
It's over. That's a fake.
Is that a fake or There's no way that's fake. Spicy chat lied
to me. It's fake. Neosick,
how dare you? How dare you? How
dare you make me look like a fool and give me a fake tweet to
pull up on stream. You son of a [__] Wait, they leaked
the actual DMs. Oh, wait. I'm I thought you said you pushed him
over the weekend. Hopefully, he's calm by then.
Yeah, sorry I missed your chat. I have it displayed on a tiny
2012 iPad right now. Lol. Also, the shout out. I was not expecting
this guy to go through my computer when I stepped out of the
room. Your message could not be delivered. Your message could
not be delivered.
Your message could not be delivered. Kathy faked it. Well, Kathy
is a tricky fellow. Okay, Kathy is
Kathy can trick people. All right, dude. How is this not This
is like the biggest PerryW of all time. I'm sorry. We've actually
gotten away from the video. I just need to reiterate for you
guys what happened here. Okay, Perry's sitting here and he reads
the Dioro sthing message in chat back at Dioro and laughs at
him. easy person. Dude, I actually brought a [__]
psycho into my room. >> But yeah, you guys just lie and
say everyone's DJ affiliates to media to pander to the few people
who fill your stream. Now he's calling me nobody. What the [__]
this nick guy is? Anyway, it's like the aura farming that that's
crazy. Okay,
I I think this is like totally this is like totally morally condemnable
behavior. And somehow my respect for Perry has grown massively.
Like like literally I think it's like the worst behavior. This
guy this guy just like
just like in I'm in a department store. They're in the toy toy
toy aisle. Okay, a parent and their child and Perry's the parent
and he just slaps the [__] out of his child and somehow
I gained respect. I don't know how he just did something objectively
terrible, but I've somehow he did it in such a funny way I've
gained respect for him. I don't even get it. Okay, I don't even
get it. How bad can Perry be? Perry's not No, I'm not comparing
Perry to IRL. I'm saying when when Aiden invites you over the
first time you meet him and you go through his DMs and then leak
DMs from Nicholas Dioro to humiliate Nicholas Dioro like destroying
one of his business connections. Uh that's psychopathic. That's
crazy behavior, right? But I've somehow gained respect for him
by doing it. It's crazy. >> I don't give a [__]
about it. You went through my computer while I was out of the
room. I did
Willy MG.
I walked out of this room and you went through my [__]
computer. No, I did. Yeah. >> How am I supposed to move
on from that? I don't know, man. Do you want to edit >> No,
we can keep we can keep going. I mean, I don't like there's nothing
I can do about it now. I just >> Yeah. No, I shouldn't
have done it, I guess, but because it is a violation of your
trust, you know? I feel like the way the way I just thought I
was like, "Oh, it's really cheesy. It was really cheap to do
that. I [__] over Nick dick and that's epic." But
then like what if like for example, if you're talking about like
a cancer family really shitty with me, right? So, it's >> dude,
Aiden is actually seething.
Oh, this is that's epic. But then like what if like for example,
if you're talking about cancer family
so badly,
dude.
Oh, this is so man.
No way. Oh,
it's so up because like Aiden has every right to be so
but it's also so funny.
>> right. So, it's just I got lucky that but to be fair
you were like teasing it. It's like oh I knew something about
I should tell you when we were at dinner, right? So, I had an
idea that wasn't like a >> Oh, wait. Did that happen? Did
you tempt him, Aiden? Did you tempt him into doing this? Were
you asking for it, Aiden? Did Perry just suggest that Aiden was
asking for it? Well, you know, you kind of did suggest at dinner
that uh there's some crazy about Nick that you he wouldn't leak
to me. You couldn't leak to me.
>> Well, yeah, I guess it is kind of like >> the
best part is if Perry is lying and never looked through his DMs.
I know for a fact that we had a I'm just going to say there's
a voice conversation that happened where it might have been said
that this happened. All right, that Nick was seething about this
and Perry, I believe, was in that conversation.
Now,
my bad if I'm leaking that on you, Aiden. I'm sorry if you're
gonna go, "Oh, just kidding, guys. Just kidding. This was all
a bit, but uh I can third party corroborate that I've been told
this. I don't know if it was by Aiden or not." Aiden was in the
conversation.
So,
but P I'm positive Perry was there. So, Perry might not have
looked through his DMs. It's possible >> like [__]
with me in hindsight for me to like go >> I was trolling
you
though. You were trolling me, were you? >> Wait, wait.
You don't think? Okay. You don't get that. That was a troll.
>> But it was like you It was real. The description you
gave was, "Yeah, Nick's trying to get me to be the >> I
didn't even say Nick. I said I'm the >> You said No, you
said Nick. No, I'm No, I did not. No, I did not. >> If
you want me to pretend, you didn't say Nick. Safe face with Nick.
That's >> No, I didn't. I trusted you with the >> He's
still trolling him. He's still trolling him. Aiden is totally
serious in this situation. And Perry is still trolling the out
of him. Oh, boy. >> Stop. That's what you asked. I said
no cuz I'll leak it. And I did leak it. But >> I didn't
tell it to you. You went to my
>> Yeah, I know. So I'm even less trustworthy. You know,
you think >> I was [__] teasing you as a troll
and my >> Yeah, but I'm saying I I That's what I'm saying.
Yeah, it was like up me. Look at your computer. It's like a violation
kind of cuz it's like you know what if there was like kind of
it's a violation kind of. Dude, this is like how to induce Stockholm
syndrome in a poor rap victim in like 30 seconds. Okay, he just
brutally armed this guy and now he's like, "Guys, come on. Don't
blame Aiden. Like, I'm the psychopath here." Like, Aiden's totally
right and is within his rights to be upset. Like, Aiden didn't
do anything wrong here, guys. Come on. Be nice to Aiden, guys.
>> It is a comment. Oh, >> you me, but at least you're
owning it. Okay, that's the first. >> Well, no. Yeah. I
mean, it's like I I get it's like kind of like to go through
your like what if I went around like imagine I went through like
your parents stuff. I feel like that's worse since I knew that
I was going to theory. Maybe it's more justified for me, but
you didn't know that. I could have done anything on your PC.
So, I understand how from like your perspective, it's like I
could have done anything there. And and it's like that little
moment, that tiny moment of trust was violated even if I'd used
it for something, you know, a bit silly like that. So, no. Yeah,
I see how it's shitty. >> I'm hurt, but at least you're
owning it. Okay. At least you're owning. >> Maybe it's
just a bit. Maybe it's just a >> I guess that's the first
step. >> Do you want to pull up to the M now? I'm not pulling
up >> because I mean I already gave a debate description
so you guys were the full things, right? To help for clarity.
So it's not like I'm being biased.
>> Both there are two sides of an issue. Both sides complain
to me about the >> You can show Queensman's too for >> I'm
not showing either. >> Well, but you can.
Aiden just said that. Uhoh. Is Queman in Aiden's DMs going like,
"Man, this Dioro guy is totally mean to me. This Dioro guy is
a total [__] What the [__] is this Dior
guy saying right now? Is that what Is that what Aiden just said?
I feel like Queman's got to leak the Aiden DMs now. What the
Aiden just said that Quimman's in his DMs about Nicholas being
mean to him. No way. Right.
Not possible. No. No. >> And why don't you? Cuz now it's
like it's just me par. I'm obviously biased. I think Nick's like
unfunny and smug and annoying. And I'm saying, "Yeah, he was
crying that Queen was calling him DG affiliated." Now, apparently
he linked like a Discord message or a tweet. I don't remember
and I'm not going to like go on your computer and do it, but
I think that So, I think you should show >> Okay, that's
a that's a direct quote I'm unaware of. Okay, that's new. And
given how Aiden is currently seething hard about this, I feel
like that's a that's a actual quote, >> dude. Dude, everyone's
telling me to ring you. Apparently, you're getting a lot of things
wrong. What do you remember the conversation that happened
>> the conver? Oh, you just said Nicholas was bman
>> I don't know months ago. Let me see >> What's
I mean and then you and then I saidqman was [__]
about Nick. >> No, I'm saying Perry's Sorry, you just said
Queen is about Nick. You said there are two parties and they
both complain to me about each other, which means given that
Nick is complaining about Queen joking about him, I'm guessing
you mean that Queman's being a whiny to your DMs about Nicholas.
So now I'm saying >> nobody's whining. It's it's just the
both both >> complaining to Aiden that is calling you DG
affiliated media. That's whining. >> Queen called me DGG
affiliated media. Oh no, he called Nick Dil.
>> Okay, I got it. >> Apparently Nick was complaining
about this to you and I'm saying that's whining. So if it's the
same if they're engaging the same behavior, then you're accusing
Quan of whining to you in DMs about Nick. >> I don't think
anyone was whining.
>> Uh complaining about jokes from the other person is
whining. I although I do understand how you need to preserve
the bridge with Nick right now, so you can't admit that it's
whining. >> There's no bridge to preserve. He burned the
bridge. I'm blocked on everything. There is no bridge. >> I
I just want you to know
you were like objectively wronged here and I I it's so it's [__]
tragic that it's so funny. I'm sorry.
>> It's okay. I mean it I if I were in your shoes, I'd
be laughing. Like if it happened to you, I would be dying >> Objectively,
you are wronged. You were totally wronged. I just want you to
know that morally, if this was like a moral question, you were
the wronged party here. Okay. >> No, but it's not even
Perry that I'm like mad at here. It's like it was a mistake on
my end to trust him like that, but then it's like why am I being
like blocked and cut off over like a
>> It is. I mean, unfortunately for you,
Nick is kind of just like really sensitive. Or maybe not. Maybe
this is all a bit. I have no idea. >> It's not. I swear
on my life there's nothing about this that is a bit but it's
like such an absurd situation. I I don't know. Like if I were
in everyone else's shoes, I would just not be believing this
at all. It is not a bit. I will swear on a >> Are you Wait,
are you telling me that this tweet is not making fun of Nicholas
>> Wait, which tweet? >> This tweet you made right
after stream is not you making fun of Nicholas. Just had some
cheesecake. >> No, I did make another tweet that I deleted
that was making fun of him. That was where I I said like it am
I the first person to lose 500 lbs in one day or some I realize
it's not good to like fan the flames right now. I'm going to
be the bigger guy. I'm not going to go chase him down to rebuild.
>> That sounds tough. >> You're going to have to
do a lot of eating to make that happen. >> That's going
to be a good one, buddy.
>> have a good stream. >> I'm having a great stream.
Thank you for the content. I really appreciate you.
Ah god,
what a day, guys. How does every day keep getting better? Day
after day. Every day gets better and better. When will this end?
I'm expecting somebody to like snap in front of my face and make
me wake up. Every day just keeps getting better over and over
and over again.
What's up? >> Sounds like a challenge.
>> Okay. Yeah. No, it's Every day keeps getting better.
It's awesome. My life is awesome right now. It's It's just never
been greater. It's It's so good. It's so
This is awesome,
dude. Just
It
sucks so badly. Like I get Aiden has every right to be mad and
upset. He's He's mad and I get it.
I get it. But >> because I the you know the violator here
have sort of like muddy the waters and I feel like it would add
clarity to the nick thing and we can move on to the William act
thing where I could continue to distract you. We could never
do the >> I should have gone to Bulgaria. Yeah. Yeah. You
should have. Yeah. >> Oh, so apparently according to Perry,
I was in the Malt news. >> Yeah, you were. Yeah. You want
to pull it up or >> I should tell the story and then pull
it >> I have theory of mind. I can look. You have to like
create a narrative, a >> Theory of mind. Wait, you're not
using >> Wait, shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Theory of mind
is your ability to Oh my god. >> No, no, no, no. You're
Okay. Is it like um What? It's not It's like when you when something
>> When I'm talking, I can understand what's going to go
through the viewer's head. How the viewer is seeing it. >> Okay.
I understand that they're a conscious entity and I'm just like
not >> You want blacks on the screen when you talk about
the mult. >> Well, that's what I'm trying to get through
that. I guess we have to
bring up news topic. I'm actually helping but I am theory of
minding and you're not. >> Uh he didn't stop actually.
He's he's Aiden. He he he's never stopped. It went from reading
the DMs to leaking the DMs talking to Nicholas to basically mind
Aiden the entire time they stream together. I guess >> this
is up. Somebody has to stop him.
I'm going to kick you out in like two
>> Was that the goal tonight? >> Just to come here.
>> I was going to It would be epic. You only be here. >> I'm
just I'm disappointed. Okay. >> Cuz it was a DM, too. >> I
No. No. It's because I thought better of you. I trusted you.
>> Perry sabotaged Aiden into making Tommy C right by accident.
Shameful. That's crazy cope. That's crazy cope from Nicholas.
That's crazy. Crazy crazy >> Yeah. No, that was from me.
I trusted you. Okay. >> Damn thing. Yeah. It was like I
did violate your trust. >> Do you know how many people
I trust? I don't trust a lot of people. >> Um, no, that's
true. That's true. Yeah. Always [__] up with me.
And yeah, no, I mean I understand like if you did that to me.
Well, I don't know. I mean, if you did to me and it was horrible,
but I guess, you know, maybe I'm just Yeah, if I knew, for example,
on my PC, I to be clear, Aiden just had his possibly his connection
torched with like the biggest creator he knows. No, like the
biggest streamer by far. Aiden's trying to be a streamer. He's
had his connection towards with the biggest streamer he knows
both literally both on the internet and in real life. Okay. It's
like it's it's
some medical thing or whatever. It's like my brother has cancer
and he saw those DMs out of so that's fair enough for you to
be upset. >> What happened? What happened is I left the
room and Perry went on my computer through my DMs. >> Well,
one just the nicknames though. That's I'm serious about that.
just make the ups. >> I didn't have time to do anything.
>> Sorry. The silence here is beautiful. My god. What's
up? How's it going? >> I heard I got accused of uh whining
to Aiden or something.
>> Oh, so basically um Perry leaked some I guess leaked
that he you were or diary was whining about you and
>> then just I'm like Aiden's like no I'm not it wasn't
just Nicholas. It was both parties complaining about each other.
And I'm like, "Oh, so you're saying Quean was whining just as
badly as uh Nicholas was. I guess we need to get those DMs leaked,
too."
>> Cuz it sounds like Nicholas was complaining about jokes.
>> Yeah. Yeah. There's What? Do we know what he was complaining
about? I didn't watch all of Perry's stream or anything. >> It
was something about So the message from Nicholas was something
about being DG like affiliated media
and then Nichol Perry said the same thing. So I don't I don't
know if he said that precisely. I don't even think I
say that about Nick.
>> Yeah, I feel like I also don't say that about Nick.
Like explicitly I'm like
used to sweeper Destiny, but I mean you sweep Destiny as well.
So >> yeah, I don't have any criticism there. Okay. Uh
I I just think it's like he burned that bridge as hard as you
possibly could. >> Yeah, I've always said the same thing.
So I don't know if he I mean if he was whining about that cuz
I definitely don't say that. >> I know. All I know for
sure is he complained about you and I'm like, "Yeah, okay, >> he
was doing that. Then show me Queen just complaining about like
nothing." >> I went and checked the DMs. I don't think
there was like any like Nick complaint I see in DMs. I know I've
definitely spoken to him off stream in VC and like argued about
various bits of coverage, but
>> I've never said that Queen was whining about Nick.
>> You said they were both complaining about each other.
Yeah, Queman has complained about Nick. I don't think Quman denies
that. >> Yeah, about like, you know, coverage stuff. It's
not usually about >> Yeah, I don't think that's I literally
said I don't think that's whining. >> Okay, so Nick has
complained like tangibly about Queen then, not just whining about
jokes and stuff.
>> Okay. What's the criticism? >> I'm not leaking
I'm not I'm not in >> cuz I know how complain about Nick.
I I'm just saying that I don't think there are those same level
of complaints because you have to basically give some very very
well thoughtout criticism of his content and I don't I don't
think
they might not be on the same level. They might not be and I
implore >> Dioro to come forward with his criticisms about
Quean. That is his decision to make. Um >> I just find
it interesting that Queen makes his publicly and I I'm not hearing
the same thing from >> Well, yeah. Obviously, no. I think
I've said to Dior I think you should do it publicly, but like
that's like really all I can do. I'm not going to I don't
>> Aiden, don't let these dudes gaslight you. Aiden, you're
in the right.
>> Thank you so much. Thank you so much, Kenny. Kenny W.
>> As much in the right as somebody can be who is wronged.
>> So true. Give Kenny the stream key already. Pack it
up. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Uhhuh. Okay.
All >> right. Now, I'm actually going to try to go to bed.
Goodbye. >> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Ah, you
[__]
I was going to put the lab avatar on him, but he's gone already.
>> Okay, I'm I'm going back to a free booting your conversation
with potential criminal. So, >> yourself. Bye. >> what's
up, Kenny?
>> We're continuing. >> We're continuing. >> Well,
it happened. I can't do anything about it. It's like, where do
we go from here? I guess uh we just let me cover a segment and
then maybe I'll think about forgiving you if you could let me
get through a stream. >> Yeah. Yeah. So, do you want me
to send you the news article? >> I I understand where to
find it. >> Oh, okay. >> But we're going that that's
next. Okay. But anyways,
if you know if you go to the Boax Instagram page, something you'll
notice. Okay. I can't even look at the full profile, so never
mind. It's all these It's like a toddler getting into like the
parents like like makeup drawer and like trying it on except
the toddler's a grown man that's like posting like photos of
the process and it looks like dude I just I need to watch like
little bits of this going forward and just see the like tiny
ways that Perry will with him now cuz I know Aiden's shook and
I know Perry's going to keep like just poking the wound like
the whole time. I know that he can't stop. He knows he has Aiden
wounded and he's just gonna keep poking that same wound over
and over again. >> It's like Heath Ledger like trying to
like method act to get into the role of the Joker in the Dark
Knight. U except instead of the Joker, it's Buffalo Bill from
Silence of the Lambs. Uh and instead of method acting, I actually
think there's a woman in a well in this person's house that's
about to be >> He looks closer though to the his ideal
self. Remember he was saying there was like the guy he wanted
to be. He looks closer to that guy. >> Well, his ideal
self is a demon from hell. So yeah. There was a guy on Instagram,
I forgot his name. I don't know, like queer or something, I think
was the name. Uh, but you don't think that like men that look
like this with like makeup, you mention I mean, you do stuff
for your face to look better. I saw on stream you were like doing
the haird dryer
or before streaming. >> I comb my hair before stream. >> Yeah.
So, I mean, you do stuff to make yourself look less quoteunquote
natural. >> No, it we were just out. My hair gets a little
messed up. >> Yeah, that's the natural way. And then you're
feminizing yourself by fixing it. that fixing your hair. Well,
I I know like hygiene is like must be some foreign concept to
you because you smell >> I do smell. Yeah. No, I I use
Listen, I used um deodorant things. >> Is it like deodorant
made from like sewer water? >> Um no, it's just I didn't
use enough. You're welcome for a long time, but to be fair, >> I
I know you think like basic like grooming and hygiene. >> You
like Listen, you like feminine your hair. You used like cologne.
>> She's fighting like in the bathroom. Sounds very feminine.
Women do. >> It was not Coke. >> Well, you said it
was Coke. So, yeah. No, I think uh there's a lot of reasons to
believe that you're also feminizing yourself in the same way
Robloxes. >> Tell Parrot you'll forgive the snooping if
he does the truffle shuffle. >> I don't know what that
is. I'm not >> That's a really old person reference. I
remember I had to Google that from like my like my uncle saying
this. The truffle shuffle. What the is this? The truffle shuffle.
It's like this. Yeah, it's this [__]
They want Perry to do this.
>> They want Perry to do this.
>> That's what they want Perry to do. Okay. Yeah, it's
the Goonies. It's the
>> Pull it up on your main monster.
>> So, let me tell this story. All right. Let's tell Perry
is like containing himself.
So, let me tell the story. Perry like literally is laughing to
himself about all the ways he's thinking of mocking Aiden right
now. >> So, let me tell the story. All right, let's tell
the story.
>> So, I
get to a hotel. All right, I get to Hold on. Hold. You're coming
into the store in a minute. I'll let
>> I'll let you talk. I know you're about to I can see
it on your face. I can see it on your face. I can see it on your
Move on.
>> You're so bad face. So I get So I get to a hotel. >> Here's
what I was going to say. >> Statistic. Like I was gonna
say, >> why do you do this thing where it's like you're
introducing a segment if not these are going to be segments?
>> Because there is somebody watching right now like they're
>> on even though there aren't going to be people re-watching
a VOD. There are people actively watching. And I think it it
doesn't make like for like much entertainment if you're just
saying things and not outlining what's happening to the viewer.
Like you still are like on a show >> without being this
way about it. That's why I was I didn't say that. Do I pick him
out? Like, I don't know. I can't get through a segment. Did we
kick him out? >> You do poll.
You do poll. I didn't say that, by the way. You distracted yourself
cuz I didn't say anything. You're right. Don't say anything,
Perry. Don't say it. I was going to say anything. >> They
actually keep going for a while with Perry here. >> I wasn't
going to say anything to be clear. Like, seriously, wasn't >> I'm
making a poll. I like It's not even that you went through my
computer that's bugging me so much right now. It's how like bad
of a streamer you I think I'm >> He's really not He's really
not bothered at all by those leaks. He's not bothered at all
by the fact that Nicholas is seething. He's not bothered, guys.
It's totally fine. It's okay. >> Doing I didn't say anything.
And you were like, "Shut up, Perry." >> I'm just saying.
But I was going to say it was cuz you used to get the kick Hayden
puls right and now now you're doing a kick pull and this feel
like >> s I'm gonna like kick you in real life.
>> Um yeah, from the house. Yeah. >> Harry, your
streams are literally unwatchable. You need 300 mg of aderall.
>> Well, that's what Aiden said. >> That's a That's
a That's a pay peg trying to cover for Aiden right now cuz Perry
won. That's totally just a pay peg covering for Aiden cuz Perry
won. >> That would make sense. >> I I asked for something
but you didn't talk in charity. That's No, that's true. Yeah.
Yeah. In my opinion, it's a bad one. I guess for you if you want
more ad. It's a good one. >> Okay. I guess the people want
you to
>> Brutal. Brutal. Brutal. Brutal.
Oh, why would you
Uh, dude, he should Perry should suggest it. Okay, do a kick
Aiden pull. Do a kick Aiden pull and let's see what happens.
Critical Quean voice crack. Kenny, you ready for a critical voice
>> Yeah, I'm ready. I'm ready. I play it. >> I'm
I'm basically one step above a pan handler on the corner, okay?
And I don't pretend otherwise. Guys, sub, donate, sub, donate,
okay? This isn't This isn't a free show, all right? We're trying
to make a living here. Oh, just got a sub. Let's go. Thank you.
Yes. That's every >> Success every day.
>> Success every day. >> Success every day.
Okay.
>> Success every day. >> Oh, just got a sub. Let's
go. Thank you. Yes. That's every day.
>> Oh, he's talking about he's he's thinking about Hassan.
I understand the voice crack. Okay. He was thinking about Hassan.
how cool Hassan is. He got intimidated, right? Hassan's 6'5 and
rich. He's successful. Queen got intimidated. Thought about it.
Sis,
I get it. It happens to the best of us.
>> you win. >> Marmad, dude, thank you for the gift.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Let's go back to >> Okay. So, anyways,
I get to a hotel. All right. I go in. I check in. They say, "Sir,
you're >> guys, we are
four subs away for another hour on the stream." Oh, uh, Henri
just followed. What up, Henriway? What's up?
That's cool. In luck. We've upgraded you to our five-star sister
property across the street. I think it's a scam. I say, "How
much am I going to have to pay?" They say, "You're not paying
anything extra." I I booked online initially. I said, "Really?
Okay. I never win anything, so I thought it was too good to be
true." And I guess it was okay. So I go to my place, right? Parry
pulls up. We go get dinner. Par comes back. Hold on a second.
These headphones just died. Give me a sec.
Give me a sec. Give me a >> Hello streamer. Hello streamer.
>> No, the headphones didn't die. They're
>> Get wired. Get wired. Headphones. Bluetooth is too much
for you. >> They didn't actually die from batteries, guys.
They died cuz they uh I don't even know. Cracklings.
Back. What's up, kid? experience. Let's get wire. >> I
don't know. Like vodka out of the [__] fridge. >> Mini
fridge. >> Mini fridge. This place has a [__]
little pool, a sauna. So Perry leaves. I'm sobering up in the
pool. And then I get into the sauna. >> Oh, you use the
pool. >> And then I get back in the pool. And then I get
back in the sauna. >> You have a picture of you in the
pool? >> I don't take pictures of myself in a >> It's
[__] up. >> And what if you take your shirts
off right now so people could like see what it look like? Then
I get out of the pool
and I finally get the Starbase debate, the thing I've been waiting
for. And there are fire alarms going off. And I've lived in an
apartment building. You fire alarms go off for no reason sometimes.
Like >> you went >> uh Alibaba, thank you for the
gifted sub. Let's go. So, I didn't think much of it, but as I'm
in the call with Starbased and Spinal, you know, I start to smell
something.
And then I get a call on the hotel phone saying, um, evacuate
the building. So, I'm like, "Oh, okay." No, they told me on the
phone to use the lift, which is you're not supposed to do. I
don't know why I was listening to them. I must have been drunk.
So, I get out. I step into the hallway and the hallway is filled
with smoke. I go, "Okay, I guess it's like a little fire, whatever."
I then get into the lift like she told me to. And as the lift
is going down,
it starts filling like with smoke.
>> Who the tells you to take the elevator during a fire?
>> And who listens to them?
>> Uh, Private Huff, thank you for the three gifted. We'll
add the hour to the stream right now. Thank you. Thank you.
One more hour right there.
We got it. We got it. Okay. But also, yeah, who tells you get
in an I thought you were supposed to do the opposite in a fire.
You don't get in the elevator. You get in the Go to the stairs
quick. >> Yeah. I'm sorry. I would be like, "No. Uh, is
there actually a fire? Can I go to the stairs, please?" >> And
I realized Paris said I was getting ancestral memories. I realized
I just stepped into a gas chamber. Okay. Cuz it was like filling
with smoke. >> Smoke is a gas. >> Like filling with
the I was like it was hard to breathe. Okay. My eyes hurt and
everything.
And then the the Is it really that funny?
And then >> it's pretty funny. >> The door to the
elevator open. The door to the elevator
>> finally opens
>> and I make it outside. Okay. I make outside to the lobby
which is filled with even more smoke.
Okay. I finally make it outside. I got to catch my breath for
a sec. You know, I'd never been in a room.
>> Like, can you emulate catching your
>> What if I hit you right like here?
>> Come on, Aiden. Theory of mind. Put the put the story
in the people's minds. Okay. They need to be able to picture
the story. Just try to catch your breath >> right here.
>> Perry's just trying to make the stream
>> Find an action puncher. To be clear, I just pretended
like I was going to
I'm going to help you out
in Jesus. a dynamic animal. >> I could do it for real,
though. >> Yeah, I could for real. Go on. >> All right.
So, anyways.
>> But that's also anti-semitic to point >> Someone's
going to like accuse you of being a domestic abuser.
>> I own it. I own it. I want to strangle this guy. >> Okay,
give me one second. I'll be right >> Many have tried.
>> The [__] is wrong with you, you freak? >> I
say I'm not saying I wanted them to
Like like put your right there.
>> I'm gonna like actually break your finger on screen.
>> Easy to pretend like like that. That's all you have
to do, man. You just copy what I'm doing. Like like that. So
you go outside.
>> Yes. Thank you for keeping me on topic. You need to
do more of that. So I get into the lobby
and I get outside
>> and I realize the ground floor is on fire and it's on
fire pretty quick. All right. And
I realized had I left a few minutes later, I would not be able
to get out of the ground floor. I guess there were people that
heard the fire alarm that just didn't go down because there are
people now on the balcony with smoke coming out of their rooms.
It's like a six, sevenstory building. So you could see smoke
coming out of their room. You could see people choking up. It
took about 20 minutes for the Maltese Fire Department to arrive
and they took their sweet ass out of time. I've never seen a
fire department like take like like they were just like they
weren't doing like some guy had to step in front of the fire.
>> That's like that's like every public service in Europe.
These Europeans are so lazy. That's like not shocking at all,
right? That's every European service. They're just so lazy. Fire
department takes like 10 years. Healthcare takes like 10 years.
>> These people haven't worked a day in their lives. >> Fire
truck and direct them to where the fire was. Okay. And they finally
get out. Well, the arts trees to be fair. They finally get out.
They're trying to put out this fire and there are people trapped
up there. So, they I know they pull pull up a drone over the
building, I guess, to see what's going on. And then they get
like a ladder or some [__] uh or no, they get the
ladder with the basket on it and they're like pulling people
off the balcony and breaking windows to get them out. Um as like
the whole hotel is filling with smoke. Um,
as I'm sitting there, some guy comes, some British guy walks
up to me and he's like, "Is the building on fire?" I'm like,
"I think so." >> It was dickers. You can just say it's
>> And then we start having a very nice
>> Yo, Metacafe, thank you for the 7 months. New individual
sub. Let's go. >> It was about 3:00 in the morning. And
I said to him, I was sobering up, whatever. He's like, "Really?
I'm sobering up. I want to get more drunk. You want to go to
the convenience store?" I said, "Sure." So, we go to the convenience
store. We buy more beers. He's like, we he's in the hotel across
the street that I was originally supposed to be staying in. So,
we go up to his room with his friend. We have a couple of beers
as we just watched the fire department rescue people. And apparently,
my voice was allegedly heard on the Maltese news. So, I I want
to check that out. >> My god. >> Good luck finding
a link. >> I'll find the link. >> I have the link.
I'm going to send you the link. >> I know the link. >> So,
why do you want to bet that I'll find the link? >> Well,
I'm not going to You'll find it. It's just going to take you
forever. >> No, it's not. It's going to take quicker than
it's gonna
>> Right there. Right. >> Well, yeah, but you didn't
find the link. Google found that link.
>> You're like typing so strangely right >> You like
sit closer. >> All right. Now, appar
Okay. I didn't copy it properly. Now, acc Shut the up. Now, according
to Perry, >> you said my name. I was going to respond.
You were like, "Hey, Perry." According to Accord,
>> Shut the [__] up. Now, according to >> you
said my name. I was going to respond. You were Perry. >> According
to Accut,
>> that's you right now. You now according to Perry, you
can actually like hear my voice. So, let's listen to this video.
>> Dude, it'd be so funny if you can't hear his voice at
all. And Aiden told this whole story think he'd like show this
on the Maltese news and Perry just lied to him and there's nothing
there. >> That would be too >> That's I can hear
my lisp. >> That's you can kind of hear it. >> Me,
bro. >> I I can hear my lisp. So, you can like kind of
hear me in the background. The Times of Malta. So, we're we're
making international news patrol.
Now, luckily, I thought someone was going to die cuz the fire
department was taking their suite out of the time. They pulled
some people out that were like treated for smoke inhalation,
but
uh and I thought someone was like up uh but everything turned
out to be fine. I then, you know, call the hotel and I say,
"So, what's the deal? Am I going to get like reimbured or you
know, my job?" Uh I call him like, "Am I going to get reimbured?"
Like, "We don't know yet." What do you mean you don't know yet?
I paid to stay in a room for four nights. I stayed in it for
four hours. Why am I gonna have to pay for four nights? >> An
insurance company. Okay, they have to message their insurance
company to figure out the situation. All right. There's all bureaucracy
involved. That's why they don't. >> But as I'm looking
into it, apparently Maltese's law does not necessarily require
them to reimburse me. >> Well, there you go. >> What
do you mean? There I go. What kind of like
look at the first Maltese person you met. The second you met
them, they went through your DMs on your computer. These are
an untrustworthy people. >> Yeah. Like you have >> country
is it where you pay for a service you don't get that service
and you still have to [__] pay. >> You got
the service you just can't access it cuz of health and safety.
It's like imagine paying for someone to kill you and then they
say I can't give that's illegal but you're going to ask >> you
get a refund. Yeah. >> Well but you're the one that's you
knew that was illegal.
>> But I didn't know that checking into the >> you
didn't know that like you can't go into a fire ridden building
a building >> I didn't know the building was going to catch
fire. >> You didn't know that. Yeah. What? Why is it like
What is wrong with this country? >> Um, well, there was
a fire for one >> And then there was another fire. Oh,
wait. And then get this. Okay, get this. It's a holiday here.
So there it's >> a holiday. It's a feast technically. >> Okay,
a feast. Whatever they call it. >> So every 2 minutes over
the bay, they're
It's not even >> Dude, does Aiden have like a 70% female
viewership? Is it like all women who watch this stream? I'm just
noticing like the chat names. It's like a purely female viewership.
What the [__] Am I the only one noticing? >> Misogynist
like you.
>> Am I the only one noticing this? Even fire. What did
your friend call them? >> Um fire sparks. >> Fire.
It's not even fireworks. It looks like anti-aircraft like artillery.
They like it into the air and it explodes, but it's not even
like a firework explosion. It's like a boom that like actually
rattles you in the windows and you do. Imagine that going. Every
two minutes I'm seeing tourists cover their ears. I'm getting
like >> it's Britney's audience. I could see it >> like
shaky. I like I >> You have to repeat your sentence every
time. Like I mean
>> my my [__] my like >> No, Perry doesn't
get to do this. Perry repeats himself too. There's no way he
going have to somebody else repeating >> I can't. That's
like uh Aiden. Aiden be
Aiden be like it be like uh uh uh he he repeats himself. That's
like a Perry segment. So, yes, >> I went like temporally
deaf for a sec. Like, it was [__] dude. It was [__]
And this went up for hours. How was that legal? My AirPods even
warned me that I was in like a, you know, I was exposed to amount
of decibels that would cause hearing damage. >> Yeah, but
that happens anyway. Went to all those nightclubs. What is that?
This accent maltes. I assume
>> you were listening to resonance on like 500 dibels.
So, there you go.
Listening, huh?
a fan of um of the fireworks. I was just um part of like our
you know culture. What can you say? >> It's I thought we
were being invaded. >> Yeah, you would think that. And
what do you mean we I was getting invaded and you were just going
to be a prison of >> Yeah, I'm on the island. >> Yeah,
you Listen, you're not part of the team, little bro. >> But
other than that, I will say it's a very beautiful country.
>> Okay. They've got some okay people.
>> they've got some okay people. here was pretty cool,
right? He was pretty open. >> It's very clean. There's
no graffiti. >> You're going to say my friend was cool
>> Your friend was cool. >> Yeah, good job. >> Um,
you know, all in all, it it's a nice it's a nice little country.
>> You not going to say my friend was cool? Can you just
you just say my friend was >> Although in hindsight, I
may have some regrets.
Uh, I will say that, you know. >> You mean like letting
me see your DMs? >> I didn't let you see my DMs. I stepped
out of the room >> being, you know, making it possible.
Was that one of your regrets? >> I'm just asking. You say
I have some regrets. Like >> because I respect I >> I
can see all of Perry's moves. Okay. I can see them all.
>> It's funny. >> I expect
you're glad I saw them. >> I expect >> You're actually
happy. >> I expect you to show some basic [__]
decency and like not like misuse the trust I've insured in you.
Like I can't leave you alone in a room with a computer. You understand?
>> Well, you could. It just involves me, you know, reading
your DMs with Nicholas or So, you don't regret that. That's what
you're saying. You don't regret >> Do you understand that?
Like, I'm being incredibly forgiving over that. Like, do you
understand if you did that to anybody else? Like, >> they
would kick me out. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That would be epic. Yeah. No, I appreciate
it.
>> You know, Aiden of all people, you think someone of
his tribe would know that appeasement is never the strategy.
Okay. When has appeasement ever worked for his people? How is
he attempting it here? >> I don't get it. I I'm still like
in disbelief kind of. I don't even want to think about it. >> Okay,
we can move on. But you said you had some regrets. So like what
are you >> Go get me another beer. >> Yeah, sure.
>> Are you really like you're that fat? You can't stand
up and get it. >> Well, if I stand up, you were going to
take a picture of me then. >> I'm not I didn't take a picture
of you. The picture came >> Wait, Kenny, did you see the
pictures? The Perry pictures? Have you seen some of these memes?
Okay. All right. I'm saying I'll put I'll put it in a BRB screen
cuz you're such a fat land well. You can't Your full body can't
be seen
>> Jesus Christ.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Why did Why did the sound go out?
What? Oh, they put on the BRB screen. What? Well, when Aiden
didn't put on the BRB screen, we got the Perry side profile.
Perry Swag. Perry >> Oh my god. >> Perry Swaggerin.
Perry Swag right there. Swinging the arms. Let's go. Let's go.
>> Wasn't that big a deal.
>> I I've never thought somebody like Listen, this guy
is fat, okay? But he's like a cool kind of fat. He's like a cool
uncle kind of fat. Okay.
>> Like he's not like a he's not like a disgusting kind
of fat. He's like a cool kind of fat. Okay. Like a funny guy
kind of fat. >> No. Yeah. You know what I'm saying? I was
thinking the same thing. Like funny guy from high school. Yeah.
>> Kind of creepy, but you know. tolerate him in the reflection.
They're going to call me fat. Whatever. >> Isn't it crazy
when you trust someone not to do something and they do it? >> Wait,
did he Did Aiden intentionally do that? Try to give away the
side profile. >> Do you know how they can see me in the
reflection? They're going to call me fat. Whatever. >> Isn't
it crazy when you trust someone not to do something and they
do it? >> move the chair. Move the chair.
>> Let's go over the Willy Mac stuff now. >> I'd
like to. >> Let's get into it. >> So, yeah. Okay.
Willy Mac reporting. See Sam does not prove he's like or alleged
sees Sam does not prove that he's somehow like not like less
compromised. Okay, if he wasn't compromis
>> proves he's less compromised than the maximum amount
of compromising that someone can be. >> I'm sorry. Nobody
was believing he was a
>> um no one was believing he was he did marry an Israeli
person. Some people are very racist.
So some people probably did believe that.
Not me. But listen, I mean, I agree. It's It's more so like a
highlight of how [__] [__] is than >> Aiden
Aiden's like traumatized.
God,
>> me. But listen, I mean, I agree. It's It's more so like
a highlight of how Destiny is than of how, you know, morally
virtuous. >> hold on, hold on, hold on. >> He was
a [__] pedoph.
>> Hold on. What where's the sound effect I'm looking for?
Like, >> hold on.
>> Um, no one's believing he was Well, he did marry an
Israeli person. Some people are very racist. So some people probably
did believe that.
Oh, me. But listen, I mean, I agree. It's it's more so like a
highlight of how [__] [__] Destiny is
than of how, you know, morally virtuous. >> No, no adjective
that was ascribed to him has been disproven by him reporting
someone for reasonable him reasonably suspecting them possessing
CSAM or sorry, CP. >> You wouldn't say that he's like,
you know, a DG for lifer
anymore. You would say he's a DG for lifer. like food shops is
still >> Yes, but if it if it takes Yes. But the point
is it it took like the possession of Seam allegedly to finally
like for him to finally draw the line like the line should have
been drawn about like 10 miles back. >> Yes or no? Is William
act better than food shops.
>> Yeah. Obvious. >> There you go. There. Now we
know this. Now we know this. >> Is Nicholas Dioro better
than >> H? That's a tough one. >> dude. Perry's winning
so hard. How is Dude, Aiden got rattled and now Perry's just
farming him so hard. >> He's fat.
>> It's a land. You said that, right? You said that. >> No,
I I called you that. >> It's hard to tell. To be clear,
still a bigger guy. >> Yo, you want to stand up real quick?
>> Yeah, we stand up. >> Yeah, stand up. >> Let's
do a high comparison. >> Stand up. Yo. >> All right.
What is this? >> Feel the f Yo, I just felt the room shift
when he stood up. Yikes. >> You totally stood up. I stood
up. Back here. Come on. >> This is crazy. He's He's like,
"Dude, you don't understand how badly
Perry is mogging right now. Perry is like literally the Any lesser
person would be sucking the gut in right now. He's like flexing
it out." He's like, "No, look how big my stomach is. >> Look
at Look at the Look at the stomach of the man who mogged you,
Aiden. Look at how big it is. Look at how stretched my shirt
is right now." Okay. I'm basically in the third trimester, Aiden.
And I owned you.
>> This is like a unique kind of swag. I've rarely seen
in my entire life. Okay, >> you [__] >> I
already show this. I'm shorter than you. I mean, people, it's
very clear. I'm going to do this gay little [__]
IRL game. This is an Asian raw stream. Okay, I'm going to do
that. I am short. I'm like 5. >> Are you that embarrassed
you can't stand >> Well, just if you're going to walk back
there, I am going to all tab and look at the Nicoians again to
be clear.
>> So, now you're in a bit of a
>> No, I'm overweight. I own that. I own that. Um, >> I
was going to do a height comparison. >> Oh, I'm sure. Yeah,
I'm 5'4 as well. >> I'm like literally towering over the
>> Well, it's hard to tell cuz you're, you know, ego is
so teeny tiny.
>> I'm saying that you are Pipsqueak at his heart. That's
what I'm saying. Um, but yeah, I mean, know some people have
put like Willie Mack and food drops in the same boat. So, >> who's
really putting Willie Mack and food shops in the same boat?
Come on. >> I think it's time for Queenie to forgive Willy
Mack. It is kind of gay that he's like going after him still.
>> Why? Okay. Why is Willie Mack not issued a retraction
or provided something to >> dude? Uh Perry's just totally
troll like honestly Aiden should just ask a specific question.
Yes. Uh so you think Quimman doxed Willie then? So you're arguing
that Willie docks >> to show that he had a reasonable basis
to believe the very consequential claim that he was publicly
spouting in his >> Okay. Saying all of these extra words
is stupid. So will he dock women then?
seen by thousands of people. >> Um, he's issued an implicit
redection by saying that this is a >> How does Destiny
being a
invalidate the claims he made about Que? >> Um, well, if
he's saying that the source was uh Destiny and now he's saying
that he's like a freak, >> but he didn't. He didn't say
that in >> Oh, yeah. He said that. Yeah, >> he never
said that in his video. >> No, that's true. That's true.
He should attraction. I agree. >> Yeah. So, maybe do your
homework next time. All right. >> He did by asking you
scratching method >> full screen. >> Yeah. Like it's
not like it's like just oh Perry walk here Perry do the truffle
shuffle. I'm going to like humiliate myself at your beck and
call stand up. That's a polite to >> I just did I just
stood up. Why can't >> yourself humiliating? >> I
wasn't I don't feel humiliated. >> Yeah because you were
point is that you're not yourself. >> Aiden really just
did get Perry to stand up to be like look at this guy he's fat.
And Perry just stood up and like around >> inside.
You should notice he used to be >> Used to be.
>> I don't I don't know. I think bully >> I'm sorry.
It's just it's >> point is that you're commanding yourself
for recommending someone else. You should notice he used to be
bullied. >> I don't know. I think bully Mac should be forgiven
by like Jason cuz it's like are you really going to like hold
his grudge forever? I heard >> it. It is literally been
like less than two weeks. What do you mean forever? >> He's
like so boring, man. He's never made an interesting video guy.
He was just like a Destiny talking piece. And if he's not that
anymore, what else? >> He's so You literally cover everything
audite does. If Ardite takes a [__] you cover it
in a video. >> This isn't even accurate. I've been ignoring
Arodite for long. Hey guys, do we know Arag is like sad pathetic
freak who like is like and like >> that is true. >> That's
every stream you do. >> According to >> Okay, Aiden's
bringing Aiden's bringing me back over to his side. Hold on.
Aiden is coming back. I didn't believe he added him, but he's
bringing it back. >> And it was so traumatizing that she
like >> Hey guys, was that Oh, let me put a seal on stream.
Let me put a seal on stream. Let me go on a 50 minute rant about
>> My seals are up. >> I'm parry. Why am I not growing?
>> I feel my seals were helping me grow actually. Also,
you have to keep in mind um do you think everyone was with SWAT
or you think that she made it up? >> I don't know anything
about her and I have no interest because it's
look at my channel. I say horrible thing to say dung devil. It's
gross thing. >> You're talking about someone else getting
molested. >> Well, Destiny better than Destiny know. I
just It's like oh it's been two weeks. Yeah. It's just saying
the same. He said Willie Mack was worse than Destiny. Quan said
you you know that, right? I'm really going to sit here and be
like, "Guys, Willy Mack is mean to me. Will Mac didn't apologize."
Yeah. Well, he doesn't have to apologize. Okay. He just gets
penetrated by his IDF bride. >> In some Wait, wait. In
some ways he is because Destiny is like shown that he like when
it comes to like things that benefit him, he has no moral standards,
right? And and technically the things that he does, right, trying
to go after Queen and Jtock
like Well, actually, you could say the same about Willie, right?
I guess it would technically benefit both. Um Oh, I don't know
what his argument is that one is worse than the other, per se.
>> Uh, actually, no. No. I think Destiny offers something.
I think Willie >> Destiny doesn't offer anything unless
you include pictures of him and videos of him sucking and the
ability to abandon a son.
>> Why the would I trust anything they say like politically?
>> So, if the claims are reliant on their credibility as
a source, then no, you don't have to trust it. If they're making
claims utilizing evidence that's publicly accessible, then the
source isn't they're not the source. They're just compiling it.
the source isn't really going to matter all that much. >> What
about the verify cuz he does debates live debates, right? So
even >> is the Jimmy Savile argument. Okay, it's a Jimmy
Jimmy Jimmy Sav verifying that those like sources are real, right?
Like I believe Destiny once said, well, they had to ban cookies
from the Gaza. They were using them for rockets. Uh the sugar
for rockets, but that just wasn't true and they were allowing
sugar in, right? So >> yeah, I don't trust you when it
comes to foreign policy, right? That's what I'm Okay, but >> hold
on. That's him lying about something that is based in reality,
Why? Why would you believe that he'd do that on foreign policy
and not domestic policy? That's that's not a good argument from
Aiden. He knows that >> that the sword >> Perry's
Perry's got him so rattled. Aiden's losing at the thing he's
best at right now. This is [__] up. >> This
is the point they got. They're >> It's like somebody mocking
Michael Jordan and then beating them in oneonone. It's just like
a high school teacher beating Michael Jordan one-on-one. Okay.
In basketball. Because he made fun of him so brutally that Michael
just was so rattled he couldn't hear anymore. >> Got two.
So he's just shown more >> in regards to foreign policy.
Yeah. >> Okay. But even Okay. So he's waiting to lie in
that case, but in me policy is just going to be fully honest.
>> Uh I can you can you can you give me an example of like
>> come on. Come on Aiden. Come on Aiden. >> He's
made out when it comes to me.
>> Can you give me an example of like of of a on an opinion
on not even a claim that you need to rely on his credibility
to trust on an opinion he's had in relation to domestic policy
that you disagree with? opinion he well just the idea that like
I don't know it's good to like make fun of uh children with poor
addictions when they get the Texas blood flood coroptics or that
that you're teaching Republicans a lesson if you're something
is that a claim though I don't know it's just but the point is
if he's willing to lie about foreign stuff why wouldn't he be
willing to lie about local stuff if he's willing to lie about
personal life why would he lie about his professional life right
I felt this way about like Elon Musk right when Elon Musk for
lying about like scores it's like so pathetic
>> doesn't really just is demonstrated to have lied, right?
In an example in his political opinions, I'll grant it, right?
I haven't seen it myself, but I believe you. I'll grant it. Correct?
So, what can be said for that? Destiny
is not credible. Okay, we're to accept that. Now, how would it
then follow that when Destiny is making reiterating or giving
an opinion giving an opinion on a claim coming from a different
You want to actually on Destiny, you go to um Aiden, do you believe
Destiny comes up with most of his own opinions or do you think
he's because I think the argument would be Desty's actual talent
is collecting many opinions and figuring out how to go,
>> Does have good analysis. He has good synthesis. That's
what he's good at. So, he lobbility.
Yes, he loses his ability to do that when his community fails,
right? When his community falls apart. If you believe in the
the Digi Jeets meme, okay, which I'm not 100% sold on because
I have many treasured Indian members in my community. I don't
want to make them feel bad, okay? But if you believe that like
there's been a great replacement of the Destiny community, of
the DG community, all right, that their original talent has been
largely replaced with
substandard, okay, arguers and and thinkers. If you believe that,
which I do very much so, okay, then you have to believe that
his analysis, his synthesis is significantly weakened as well.
Okay, that would be the theory. So, he is not the same person
he was. >> Different source, which we can then go and independently
verify if it's true or not. Why would that automatically have
no value? Because he's not credible if he's not the source of
that claim. >> Well, so does have no I'm not saying he
has no value. Everything has even liars have value. >> So,
then what are we disagreeing on? The point is that like when
you say value, you're saying >> you just the whole this
whole line of dialogue started because I said Destiny at least
offers a little value. >> When you say value, right, obviously
things have value. Liars have value. Schizophrenics have value.
>> It's not like minute, right? He has some like pretty
good prescriptions on domestic policy. >> Prescription
on domestic. Yeah, most people do.
>> No, they do not.
No, they do not. >> Also, I don't even agree with that.
Destiny is >> I don't know if you've like seen America
like recently. I just don't think that's very true. >> Okay,
sure. I guess in America they probably don't. What like good
opinions of domestic policy? He's like spurs out about rent control.
He cries about the middle class. He thinks that children should
talk to him about what what domestic policy you know I'm struggling
to think right now. I mean he's like left-leaning. He's like
liberal or >> He kind of took that one into real world
to actually put into practice as well. It's kind of fun. >> Let's
call him a communist. That's what he is. Um
communist. >> No, I'm just calling that cuz it annoys him.
Um sure. So he like copy pastes the democratic um >> I
think his arguments I think his arguments in relation to January
6 are pretty strong. >> His arguments
>> his arguments
>> his arguments yeah like it's
>> I think his like I think his emphasis on like how we
should be focusing more on like the false slate of electors as
opposed to like the actual capital breach itself. >> Pisco's
argument >> is like a point that like
kind of changed my perspective. Oh, I think Aiden is uh Aiden's
a little too caught up. He doesn't know that. Um
he doesn't know. Yeah, he doesn't know >> on that. I now
if I'm arguing this. >> Where's the video? Would the video
matter at this point? Realistically, him making that video is
going to guarantee Trump and Pam Body come after him. So, I don't
think he make that video anymore. I think that video is gone.
>> I guess if he makes the video, it's the best timeline.
focus on the false electors cuz that's like way more like personally
damning to Trump >> cuz that shows like a level of like
coordination and sophistication that shows like an intentional
plot to overthrow the Democratic election as opposed to like
where you can have plausible deniability and say oh it was just
a crowd rioting when it came to like uh when they actually breached
the capital grounds. So I think like his emphasis on the false
set of election to you is good. My issue would be that, you know,
I wouldn't want to I wouldn't trust anything less than he says
because I know he's just willing to lie if it benefits him. That's
my issue is that why the [__] am I It's like it's
good. I could pretend. No, Pisco is way better at these arguments.
Pisco is better at the analysis and coming up with the arguments
in the first place. Um like way better. These are Pisco's arguments.
Pisco had to convince Destiny of these things, right? >> That
one. >> Okay. So then for that for that claim, then you
wouldn't even use him as a source. You put the idea in your head
and then you can go and verify. He's like a relay for like like
in good >> That's what a lot of political commentators
are. >> Yeah. But it's like um
it's just you use him as a curator and hoping he's >> wait
what do you think political commentators do? >> They what?
They commentate on politics. >> Yeah. Yeah. They're they're
analyzing political situations and and making prescriptions.
>> Yeah. But it's like if I want to Okay. In the world
you're saying where anything anyone says you just double verify
it or whatever. Sure. That's you should be doing that
way people engage with it, is it? >> No. Then then that
but that's but that's but that's a critique of me illiteracy
amongst the general populace. >> But then you can't critique
anyone who lies over some high >> Oh, Porter Bellar is
over there making this exact point I did. Okay. He stole that
point from Pisco. Yeah, that's just Pisco Pisco's analysis. Destiny
didn't even believe that until Pisco argued and and made him
understand it. >> You know, you can critique them. You
can >> I saw we were watching yesterday that stream from
yesterday. He's like, I don't even watch other streamers. It's
like I hope that's not true cuz uh if you're not watching Pisco,
you're probably not going to understand how to argue the next
point that comes up. So, good luck.
No, you can critique them for their lies, but when they But that
doesn't mean now we are to assume that every statement is false.
>> They have value. It doesn't have value just as much
as Sam Hyde. >> I don't think Sam Hyde does cuz even if
Sam Hyde's not lying, like all his political takes are >> Yeah.
But you're meant to like crossverify them. And from doing that,
>> Yeah. But when you crossverify them, you realize they're
still not true. >> Yeah. But from doing that, you'll see
the true claims and you'll learn about them. Okay, but with Okay,
so when Destiny makes a prescription about the false slate of
electors, you then go and verify and realize that adds up. What
he's just described to you is like the actual something about
racial memory and you realize that's full of [__]
Then you realize, oh wow, so that's not how race works. So that's
the value some height provides
>> the value in I guess you could argue it's value in him
being like laughably wrong. You're getting >> in a way
makes it so that >> you're getting an example of like somebody
like laughably wrong. Sure. >> So they have just as much
value as each other. Uh I wouldn't say that >> if you're
interfacing in a way where they bring something up, you double
check it in order to see whether or not it's true. Yes, they
have the same amount of values as one another on just the topics.
That would be the difference is what topics they talk about.
So yeah, maybe that gives more value to talk about things where
senpai talks about >> again.
I can't even see that pop up, but I assume it's rating with whoever
the these viewers are. The queen raiders, welcome. Welcome Queen
Raiders. FB0000, is that feudal pathos?
You just got mentioned the other night. What's up, buddy? Oh,
what's up, Queenman Raiders? How's it going? We're watching Aiden
and Perry. We just watched uh we're watching Perry brutally mo
and or a farm from Aiden. Okay, he's just he's just been ora
farming this entire time. Aiden had it some tiny moments, but
he really has provided no push back. He's just slowly been farmed
by Perry this entire time.
>> Do you think Do you think a guy that is like Do you
think a guy that is like planting like correct prescriptions
off of like situations that we can >> How did you know?
How did I know that it was queen rating or that FP000000 might
be feudal pathos?
Because uh I remember all names of everybody all the time. I'll
never forget names of chatters. I'd have to hit like thousands
and thousands of viewers to not know the name of like all my
chatters and remember them. But also,
>> you were mentioned. Yeah, it was something about you
talking about food shops transness being triggered by some medication.
I was I was being told this the other day.
I remember all these people. I know all these people. I remember
all of them. Okay.
Yes, I remember you, Spud Gun. Of course I do. Of course I do.
All right. And the raid the raid is always from Queenie because
that's the only other person. Vetamines and meds for restless
leg syndrome. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Not joking. That did come up. All right. Anyway, we continue.
We're just watching uh we're just watching Perry casually mo
Aiden. Okay. Uh Aiden got so rattled that he he told Perry to
stand up. He thought he was going to show off that Perry was
fat and humiliate him. And Perry stood up and stuck his gut out
and and just rumbled over and Aiden was totally mogged. Okay.
Aiden was totally mogged by Perry's stomach.
All right, it's over. >> To be objectively true. Do you
think his like statement in regards to that situation is going
to be more valuable than the guy that is like cherrypicking objectively
true situations and then making like a prescription that is like
logically invalid and unsound and then like planning that into
people's heads? >> If you could actually trust that he
was telling the truth, then yes. But since you can't, you have
to double check. >> No, you can by then going and verifying
his frames in separate soldiers. >> You cannot trust cuz
you have to double check it. >> Wait, how did you >> Hold
on. I'm getting told to that we should pin this that we should
play this for the queen raiders. Hold on.
>> Jesus, that's a lot of audio
>> Jesus Christ. I don't know why that's triple overlapping
like that, but that is the successful successful voice crack.
Let's go. You know, the sugar thing was a lie.
I have no idea if it's a lie or not. I'm pretty sure it's a lie.
I heard someone say it's a lie. >> How can I trust the
words you say? You stated that so factually.
>> Okay. Got up. >> But my point is that if you're
saying that you trust them and you double check regardless. But
yeah, but at that point you're able to trust anybody and double
check what they say. So the only benefit of them is >> you
know you know you're making a argument. I feel like I'm wasting
like I'm going to have >> even write down my argument if
you tried. You couldn't cuz >> So true. Okay. Yeah. See,
so let's watch the Willie Mac video. >> Cry, baby. >> Yeah.
Just [__] behave, please, >> Yeah, you were.
Okay, you were behaved there. I'll save Bob. >> All right,
I'll pathetic you saved. You were going to say I was liar. No,
you
>> Earlier this. >> I didn't mean to open that. >> I
reported Destiny. >> I didn't mean to. I actually didn't
mean to open that. I was trying to open my stupid sound effect.
>> I like a fake. >> No, I'll read donuts here in
a sec. By the way, guys, thanks >> to the police. This
is not clickbait and entirely has to do with the DMs he sent
me. A few days ago, a Reddit post showed that the girl Destiny
shared Pixie's nudes with was seemingly confirmed to be 17 years
old due to her getting docks. There is almost a 0% chance that
she was not 17 during that time. So, I do what I usually do and
reached out to get a comment. He said the girl wrote >> Ky
Farms post was a reading post of Ky Farms. That's where you saw.
That's fair
>> Told him she was 19 and in college at the time and that
the leaker Solo, who is her ex-boyfriend, confirmed that she
lied about her age to him. This is true. In similar scandals,
this is where people usually argue, is he lying? Did he actually
know the age? Is it his fault if he was catfish? I usually wait
for all the details to come out before I comment. This is not
why I went to the police. It's because he continued to write,
"I didn't know this until way later, but the video she recorded
with other guys, the file names are like screen recording blah
blah blah." And then he shows me his the top of a video clip.
And you misclicked. You >> Oh my god. >> So my question,
>> what did you click? M
J. Okay, go ahead. >> So how would men's rhea apply in
regards to the possession? Right. I'm I'm pretty sure it would
just be illegal across the board regardless of his intent.
>> What's up? How's it going? >> How How cool is
it that Parry just came into Aiden's hotel room and started disrespecting
him and
>> boundaries and so I I like feel bad for Aiden legitimately,
but it's so funny that I can't not laugh. And like, >> have
you seen all like the the pictures and edits and being >> Yes.
Yes. I've pulled up 10 different edits of Perry being fat, of
Perry's massive tummy. Okay. Right. >> I filled up so many.
Dude, this is like he just won so hard. Aiden Aiden like tells
him to stand up. Like Aiden's going to mo him because he's taller.
And Perry, a a lesser man than Perry, okay, would suck his gut
in here. Perry like sticks it out. So his his shirt stretches.
He doesn't give a Okay.
He
I can't. He's like the coolest fat guy I've ever seen. Okay.
>> Oh, it's so
He's the coolest fat guy I've ever seen. Okay. It's over. So
afraid you know he's like 5'4 as well, right? Like he is like
tiny apparently. >> Doesn't matter. Yeah, he's like robotnik
coded. Okay, get this guy [__]
>> H
the one of him just like walking
>> What's up? >> On a more serious note, can Perry
talk anybody after this?
>> Taking away his [__] rides. >> Why
can't he Why can't he talk?
Just him like walking over. I don't know. He's just so like he's
so calm and confident. Okay. >> Look like a penguin. He
look like a
>> And this is this is this guy was cool. I I've never
I didn't think somebody could own being fat like that and just
be so cool. I'm I'm totally on that. I'm a Purple Perry fan now.
Okay. Purple Perry Gaming. I think I'm already subbed, but if
I wasn't subbed, I'd sub right now. Um, I think when it comes
to CP
>> He's just so [__] mad. He's like >> he's
funny. >> He's He's funny because he like sat here and
then when Aiden's like mad at him, Aiden's like barely stopped
seething about the DMs and Perry's just like totally with him
like repeatedly like cutting him off saying, "Dude, why don't
you just pull the Do you want me to send you the link? I'll just
I'll send you the link." Aiden's like, "No, I'll find the link.
I'll just send you the link." He's just [__] with
him, not letting him run his own stream the whole time. They
called into Becket like last night
and um or the night before
and Perry was like, "Becket, do you want to see this picture
of my cat?" And then he starts going, "Look at this picture of
my cat." So just on voice. Aiden's like, "You can't see it. He
can't see it." Dude,
why? You can just imagine Paris sat there like holding his phone
out to Aiden's phone. I come from so >> Oh, I pointed this
out as well. Just the all-white outfit like takes balls. Okay.
just an all-white outfit.
That's uh I don't know. That's pretty
>> He believes they're of age, which we don't even know
if that's true, by the way. It probably isn't. But no, you could
say No, you could say reason to suspect she was underage, but
like willfully look the other way, right? Is that a fair assessment?
>> Yeah, reason to suspect. Yeah, I love reason to expect.
Like especially if their parents had braces, couldn't meet up
with him. >> Okay. The braces point is not really that
strong. >> Well, just like, you know, it's insillar information,
right? Like if somebody says they have picked >> Yeah,
exactly. All white dad's 10 pounds. Dude, all white. If he was
wearing all black, he'd be like skinny and cool as well. Okay.
He could have concealed that gut with black clothing. He didn't
want to do it, though. He wanted to He wanted to mog with that
>> He wanted to mog with the gut. He didn't want to conceal
it. Okay. He didn't want to hide it.
What the [__]
Wait, wait, wait. I've got one for you. Wait. Brutal.
Brutal. Brutal. Brutal.
Yes. Yes.
>> I'm going to maintain. None of this has broken my resolve
that he's too cool right now. Okay. I get you can make fun of
him. He's He's just too cool to care. All right. I'm I'm telling
you. >> You imagine him to be. Um there's insilario information.
He didn't have proof. I there's claims that and these aren't
as strongly shown that he did ask for idea and she brushed it
off, right? But barely >> Oh, hold on. Now that you guys
are here or now the queen's here, you watch the Connor thing,
right? Is it not insane
>> to try to explain why other people are like going crazy
or they're being hyperbolic and [__] while not like
actually looking into any of the information yourself by maintaining
that Rose had an only fans, right? By not knowing that Solo informed
Destiny that she was under 18. Like I think that's wild that
he and then he says, "Oh, it's not sweeping because I'm not denying
something bad happened." Yeah, but if you don't look at any of
the facts, like you're obviously sweeping
is like it's >> Um I mean, he could say he literally doesn't
care. >> He just did four a 4 hour stream on it. >> Well,
yeah, but he doesn't he like you know none of the facts even
if you know matter what it is. If it's like some 17year-old where
he wasn't 100% sure it's not going to change any of his
>> Well, his analysis is about knowingly committing a crime,
right? And Destiny had a reasonable expectation that she could
be under 18.
It should totally affect his analysis. It should totally change
his analysis.
>> Maybe
it won't. >> Okay. Well, I know it won't, but I mean, it's
obviously
obviously it's insane. It just is. I was looking to see if I
had a different ketty. Apparently, I don't have a different Kenny.
Oh well. Oh well. >> We know he doesn't have ID. It's fair
to She doesn't have idea cuz we did. >> Well, I wanted
Well, for those for that specific conversation referencing, we
don't have her side of the DMs. Correct. >> Yeah. No, we
don't. That's why. That's so weird. >> So, we don't know
what she sent her. >> But regardless, we um can infer that
he never got sent an ID or something like that. Um >> legally,
I think legally this implicates him. I think morally speaking,
I'm viewing him like exactly the same as I would from like the
guy who's sharing non-consentual. Like I'm not viewing him as
like like this is the thing that makes him so much like more
like >> I'm kind of on the same page as Aiden. Like I already
knew like once she was 17 it's like okay well I already knew
he received from her so isn't shocking. I I would say the only
thing it's not moral like changing. It's more I think this guy's
a complete [__] now. Like the fact that he would
make a group chat and then send this to all these people after
being told that she might be under 18 or being told she was under
18 but you know from a source he didn't trust >> tell Willie
Mac they still had it >> and telling Willie Mack. Dude.
And I don't know when this comes out later or if there's other
stuff that proves this, but literally Tommy C pulls up the clip
showing that Willie Max's like talking to a group chat while
he's like running through these decisions. That even changed
your opinion after he DM'd you. He didn't know she wasn't a minor.
Uh, wait, hold on. He said he didn't know she was a minor. I
I think he didn't know. if he had just taken this to the cops,
like if he had if he'd basically reported this to somebody like
right away when when the solo guy informed him when he if he'd
like basically gone, "Okay, somebody's telling me that I have
red flags there, right? And then from there, you should be able
to go and go, "Okay, I need to I need to make sure I'm covered."
But he didn't do any of that. So, I don't think he knew she was
a child.
Did he want to know? Did he actually make an effort to know?
No. But I don't think he like knew for sure she was a child or
something. It was like hiding that. So, I think he's got plausible
deniability in the initial exchange. The issue is the two months
between the preserv the the evidence preservation request, the
the what is it? notice notice to preserve evidence from Pixie
and when he was informed that she was under 18. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Like he he was aware of the possibility she was a minor. Yes.
And there's proof of that. Yeah. Absolutely.
Absolutely. So remember that episode of House where Foreman intentionally
infects Cameron with a no unknown virus. So both have motive
to find a solution. That's Destiny with his group chat. You show
them all to see Sam and you go, "Okay guys, now I have to tell
you she might be under 18. If we don't find her, uh other people
might prove it before us. will be find her. Find her. Now,
>> for me, this thing is not that much. I'd say the non-conentual
sharing of nudes is like on a moral level worse than whatever
this is, which is why it's like so bizarre to me. >> Cuz
people are just both reckless. >> Yeah. But I don't know
why Willie No. No. One, I think the the first part like this
part you can try and maybe argue there was like willful ignorance,
but for the first part, it's like clearly intentional, right?
Um,
well, I mean, I think they're both Yeah, I think that they're
in one case he doesn't care about agent consent. He just wants
to, you know, >> do you see that Perry thinks you need
to apologize to Willy Mackman?
Are you ready to apologize? >> No. What [__]
this guy saying? >> He says you need to apologize. >> Uh,
engage with this person. In the other case, he doesn't care and
wants to humiliate Pixie and all your people showing him to do
this with. I think that, but I don't know how you could claim
that one is definitely malicious. You could claim he's just reckless
and he's like in a goon state. That's what Destiny says. is like,
"Oh, I wasn't on Vance. I was just like gooning so hard. I was
even thinking." So, I don't know that you can definitively say
it. I would agree with that, you know, clarif
>> um as far as my What was I going to say? Something something
um
having the new Yeah, it would be illegal regardless as far as
it being it would it would be reckless to engage with a minor.
Um >> I just don't accept anyone who is jumping ship over
the 17-year-old. I don't think they have a moral compass and
I don't accept you. I don't accept you because I don't feel as
though this was like so much more substantially wrong than like
the the images part that this is where you're getting off like
the boat talking about
>> what is I don't accept you. What is this guy on? >> Um
DG. >> I have no idea. I have no idea. Okay, you could
say, "Okay, it's great. They're finally like, you know, get jumping
off a sinking ship or whatever the but in my mind, the non-conensual
sharing of images, it's like with this you could with this, there's
still an argument of w willful ignorance. with the images. It's
like a knowing repeated action and then in the aftermath of it,
his ability to it's like twisting and distorting of the narrative
and attacks on the people whose
images he shared who he knowingly violated to this extent. Like
I feel like this is just like way way worse than like oh the
19-year-old was actually 17. >> As far as it being worse,
>> I mean especially because you knew she might have been
under 18. I don't think Aiden's like totally wrong here that
like probably
the difference between her being like these ages
and Desi like not being sure about it. I don't know that I have
like all the moral condemnation in the world. Like I I think
Desi is already like a confirmed piece of [__] And
if you're like, "Oh, now that he's he texted somebody who was
17 or somebody who's 17, actually he is really bad."
Yeah.
I don't know what the accepting you thing is, but I I get I I
totally get how like this isn't really changing the moral condemnation
you have for Destiny. Like you already think this guy's a total
piece of [__] or you're
>> Okay, I I'd agree that the search sharing is worse than
this. >> Like the first thing is so bad to me. I find it
like hard to like be like that. >> The point would be that
like William Mac there's like reasonable doubt in the other case
whereas this is like even if it's not as bad of a thing, there's
it's like definitive because Destiny's like literally sending
it to him whatever. >> I guess that would be the thing
William Mac would say. It's not about which is worse. It's about
this being he literally showing me the proof that this is the
case. >> Wait, Smaggle, you're so you're so it meets a
legal criteria for something, but that doesn't mean you derive
your like moral framework from the law. >> Like it would
be a bit weird to cuz I think it is, you know, disgusting. It
shows that Destiny doesn't care about hate consent and just wants
to get his rocks off with people that he play with these people.
But it doesn't mean that it's like at worse than the over and
over again like sending images without consent or going people
without consent. I think that there's way more malice in that
than this encounter. Even if this one would be illegal, I think
>> So, does does Smaggle believe there's like not not legally
speaking, would Smaggle believe there's like a substantial moral
difference between like having a video of a naked 17-year-old
the day before she turns 18 versus the day after? Obviously not.
Obviously, like the distinguishing thing is going to be the legality.
>> Well, some people think that just like breaking the
law is in of its own way like a bad thing to do. I don't know
if that's how >> I I think it is. I think No, no, no. I
think it is right. I think it under like rule utilitarianism.
I think the age of consent reduces harm >> also that just
some people would see it as like if you're breaking a clear law
like in this case it's very clear that he has this material and
I believe that his you know arguments about the having to save
it or whatever
um it's very clear he's breaking the law so I think you know
you could say it's way worse in a case where he's definitely
breaking the law whereas with the the picking where it's not
even criminal courts right it's a civil course that would be
an argument you can make for why this is worse than the other
thing is that the clarity and the the just blatantness of the
breaking of the laws make it worse makes it worse
>> let me just Three donuts real quick.
Uh, Sirion with the five. Par, your streams are literally unwatchable.
You need 300 milligrams of Adderall. Benz Benz with a two. Wait,
Aiden. >> Make him donate again. >> He did. He did
read that twice. >> Wait, Aiden, do you take Adderall?
No, I don't. Jimberly with a 10. >> Essentially, Lucas,
yeah, essentially.
yeah, essentially. >> Why does Parry just look like a wide
loner box? Holy smokes. Get this zero off the screen. True. Well,
I am a >> Aiden. How much to turn your head and spit on
Perry's? >> It's like inverted dimensions. Loner box. Loner
box. Tall and skinny. Very short and wide.
>> Three and a half. I would never spit on anybody. I think
that's like very low class. Like punching him is another story.
But spitting on him, I would never do that. >> I felt that
grip on you was for a while. That was tense. >> The grip?
>> Yeah, the grip.
>> Yeah, that was pure anger. >> Yeah. So, so >> I
had to restrain myself. >> You already went beyond spitting
is my
Does Perry hold others to this standard? I don't know what standard
you're talking about. Uh Perry, uh can you confir Can you confirm?
Is it P? Okay. >> No, it's not as ping because obviously
if it's been exposed to the elements longer, it wouldn't be pink.
>> That sheep Cassie was holding on to Perry's wrist for
dear life. You can hear the steel. >> It actually called
Lucer >> Link's creaking and squealing. This is so messed
up. True was recording on Skype call. That's absolutely insane
to think about him doing all of this if she was 17. Well, this
is insane to me because he's saying Rose's boyfriend recorded
CP while sending me a of the alleged CP. So, I asked to confirm
if he just did that. If you were sending me this, I'm guessing
you still have that video. Destiny replies, "Depends on why you're
asking, but yes, I created copies of all of our messages and
everything when that court case started." Just to be clear, he's
admitting to having alleged CP downloaded on his computer. He
literally has the video open as I'm talking to him. I go, "Bro,
there's been >> So, what do you think about this part
I don't know why Willie I don't know why Willie said that he
literally has the video open as I get sorry I get why he's saying
it as in there's a screen from it but it seems pretty obvious
that that screen would be from something else he said to other
people but >> oh depends why you're asking sweats to me
what do you think about that people are talking about that thing
>> are recording these on Skype that's just absolutely
insane to think about him doing all that if she was 17 if you're
sending me this I'm guessing you still have the video depends
on why you're asking but yes I created a copy of all our messages
and everything when that court case start. Yeah. So that's like
an admission. He still has the video. But to be clear, he's saying
if she was 17. So there's like just to be clear, if you suspect
that, you should be deleting it off your hard drive. But like
we don't he may not clearly believe that she's fully underage
yet, which is still even if you have a suspicion, it should be
wiped. >> Also, he, you know, later goes on to say, "Well,
my law I told my lawyer about this." >> No, I haven't got
to that part of the video yet. This is like >> So I'm asking
you, people are saying, "Oh, depends why you're asking." And
>> I got to turn on the air, dude. One [__]
I'm like dying in here. >> I'm just very intense. I'm very
intense, you know. Oh, so when you So when you move away, you
mute it. You want people to see your >> You can turn it
all. You can put it on if you want. >> Oh, I mean your
your your freaking
you know your body. >> My body? >> Yeah. It's like
you hid yourself. >> This is my body. Okay, stand up. >> You
already did. I already did. Listen, we can do the thing now that
you're not as seated. Okay, we can go back there and stand. >> Yeah,
stand up. >> We stand there. Obviously, you're taller than
me. Oh god. Okay.
>> Shock shaker.
>> Look at me. >> Moged. Moged. Moged. Aiden's totally
>> Little [__] >> Like that. Is it in
trouble?
>> No. You ever seen The Dark Knight Rises >> Well,
I did. I remember that scene.
>> Oh, [__] >> What's in your chair?
>> I'll get it later. Do you think either one of these
guys could throw like a ball in a direction reliably?
Like do you think any of them has any muscle like uh what you
call like muscle chain, you know, training at all? Like did either
of them do sports? Are either of them like physically capable
in any way? I feel like they'd both be the least coordinated
people. >> Like every fat Turkish guy ever. It's so funny,
man. >> Coordination. I'm talking about coordination. You
know how you can train muscle chains to work together? Like you
if you don't really learn how to like throw or do things like
as a kid, you don't really know. That's what that's what I'm
talking about, Jacob. Like, could either of them throw a touchdown?
Is it even remotely possible?
I feel like there's just no way. Ever heard of a muscle chain?
Really? A muscle chain or myofascial chain is a series of interconnected
muscles that work together through connective tissue to enable
efficient, coordinated movements and provide structural support.
Yeah. Yeah. >> See, I would do it. I just don't want to
be bossed around it. Wait, you're reading your [__]
Oh, is it just >> I can't throw a football poison. >> Okay.
All right. >> I'm just doing it in a stupid way. >> Here,
I'll fix it for you, man. >> I don't trust you to touch
my computer, >> Shouldn't throw it back, Perry. That's
so disgusting. And did the green person clarify what they mean
by that donation, by the way. You can scroll up and see.
>> Perry is thick. Okay. Perry is thick. I'm going to donate
for Perry to borrow back on stream. >> Perry is a torra.
What? >> Tora. It's like a food. >> Anyways, this
guy tried to post a photo of me mogging me. Just to be clear.
>> No, I post a cuz you posted a photo of me. So, I post
a photo of you to be >> But I posted a photo of your upper
body to be clear. Just so I wouldn't >> I posted a picture.
You did the same thing cuz you took a picture. >> No, I
didn't care. I actually looked at the picture you posted me to
be fair. >> Yeah, you look fine. Matt looks fine.
>> dude. Could you imagine Perry doing like a tumbling
routine? This is so true. Perry doing back flips would be funny.
Perry just doing like a Could you imagine if he like had training
as like an acrobat? As like a gymnast do like a tumbling routine,
bro. He'd be like He would be like Jack Black then. He would
be totally Jack Black coded. >> Aiden, can you do Cab Cab
Dawn? What does that mean?
>> Oh my god. >> I have no idea. >> why do
you zoom in? >> Fake anime fans >> put Okay, this
is getting ridiculous, man. I don't like Latinos. In my race
tier list, they were in Dtier. >> Whoa. Thanks for sharing.
We don't care. >> You don't know my race tier list. You
should care. You >> lumpy Willy. How can you be this large
in Europe? Embarrassing.
>> No. It's so cool. I don't know. I Dude, people are out
to lunch on this one. It's so >> Lumpy Willie, how can
you be this large in Europe? Embarrassing.
>> I very hope he's the great guy. >> I made this
guy walk today, though. I made him walk. >> I walked longer
earlier before we met, by the way, just to be clear. I literally
walked to the bus. >> My problem wasn't walking. My problem
is I had to pick and we were going to Spark >> Okay. I'm
sorry. I have to do this, but uh never mind. Never mind. I'm
not I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not Never mind. >> He's
a multiate. Let's go. >> Okay. Anyways,
>> yeah, you're we're doing the William >> Yeah,
I forgot we're doing that.
>> Oliver. But yes, ladies, I am single. Um, so please
send me photos of your in DMs, especially if you're 17. All right,
>> Uh, is that just not like a really really bad idea on
YouTube?
>> I don't know why you just did that. That was a crazy
thing to do right there.
>> What are you doing, bro?
>> Destiny's for sure. >> Messages and everything
when that >> He really is. He's He's more loyal to Destiny
than anyone. Jesus. >> Poor case started. Just to be clear,
he's admitting to having alleged CP downloaded on his computer.
He literally has the video open as I'm talking to him. I go,
"Bro, there's been allegations at least since my last video that
she was underage and you still have potential CP of her." He
replies, "I have an obligation to preserve relevant evidence,
etc." So, I created backups of all of the important/relevant
conversations. He continues, "I don't think I'm allowed to delete
it." >> Epic comment. Yeah. >> Go on. Why would you
>> I I it's just like baffling to me that not only does
he not realize like like I don't understand how he doesn't realize
how incriminating like the statements he Do you think he like
gets off on like doing the most controversial things possible
and see if he can get away with >> Um I do think he has
a humiliation
>> in like connection with many other things. Yes. >> Um
but not just for him for >> Well, it's almost like a challenge.
Um I think that so I think it's very fair to say that Destiny
gets off on humiliating women, right? like in those DMs where
he reveals I'm talking about himself here. >> Yeah, that's
that's what I'm thinking. So, if we know that he enjoys humiliating
other people, obviously he enjoys the plug stuff, right? He wants
to get plugged with the >> Rose person. Did they even say
matching plugs? There was the the babysitter >> Destiny,
I think it was Rose that said we should get matching, wasn't
it? Or was it Destiny? Somebody said they should get matching
plugs >> in the babysitter DMs, right? Where Destiny is
doing roleplay where there's a baby or babysitter and obviously
the kid. Destiny's the kid in those DMs, right? So, there's a
fair point to be said that Destiny
wants to be in a humiliated role and it would be fair to say
that since Destiny obviously was when he was younger. Um, it's
possible there's like a thing there where you know since he felt
unsafe as a >> that's not funny. Okay, what's funny there
is that Aiden is seething about Barry talking about this on his
stream. Okay, in and of itself that is not funny. It is just
funny that Aiden seething
he wants >> here. Hold on. Let me back this up >> And
it would Right. So there's a fair point to be said that Destiny
wants to be in a humilated role. And it would be fair to say
that since Destiny obviously was when he was younger. Um it's
possible there's like a thing there where you know since he felt
unsafe as a kid due to being he wants to be able to live or I
guess relive his childhood in a way where the non-safety due
to being by like his uncle >> it just keeps becoming I'm
sorry it's relevant like every time Perry says something crazy
and he just kind of sits there silently like seething about it.
Uh like so I think it is fair to say accumulation fetish. Uh
but as far as why he sent this to Willac, I think he was like
van out kind of like you right now spurging out moving back and
forth in his room desperately doing damage control. That's what
I think.
>> Thanks for the input.
>> Come on, man. >> I still I still like Dustin.
>> All right. Lol. I don't know if it counts as hiding/destroying
evidence. And I reply talk to dude.
>> He's so he's so mad. And Perry Perry's like having so
much fun. It just you can't win. Okay. Perry's having so much
fun with this dynamic and he's so upset about it. Should have
just kicked him out maybe. Thank god he didn't though. >> To
a lawyer that seems crazy to me. Who keeps this sort of stuff
on their computer without 100% knowing if they're supposed to
or not? Isn't that something you want to confirm? I continued.
You >> Why is this like So she's 17. Why is it so crazy
to believe the guy that is non-consensually sharing intimate
images of women is going to have like a 17-year-old? Why is that?
>> Well, it would be crazy cuz it's like another level
of legal re like >> No, you just like [__]
it up again.
>> Your thing. >> I'm going to take this. I'm going
to crack it over your head.
>> Hope you don't get lost.
>> but you know, I think it's fair to say it's beyond right
like the amount of at one point versus now. I think it's is like
another level. But as far as I can't stand, you know what I can't
stand? when you use the word child. Okay, I was talking to that
person that was talking to Moral. She was 17. She's like, "He
manipulated me. I was a child." And I'm like sitting there 19
years old. I'm like, "What are you talking about? Grow the [__]
up." >> But for to be fair, first of all, Rose >> Aiden
had incredibly positive interactions with older men when he was
a minor. Okay. Why can't you guys >> Why can't you guys
one thing? So, it's only like Rose. >> I know. I was talking
about the >> I understand. I understand that. Second of
all, >> I'm saying I cringe when I hear people refer to
17year-olds as I think there is something to be said though about
the fact that obviously if he's being reckless here keeping CS
Sam and not looking for the age of consent doing this with this
person right like who else would you switch right anybody that
>> he's illegal yeah it's illegal so much it just shows
that like you know there's like a range of like recklessness
regarding the law the law
>> yeah exactly I agree saying kid or what saying child
is a bit like the meaning but you know um I guess it would be
on becoming a boy I don't know what he said about like CP stuff
where if he says Oh, all of it equally is bad. Um, I understand
people on YouTube are like that, right? Where they're like, "Oh,
>> Not a single one of you disagree. Are you talking about
like the 17 thing not really being like that crazy?
It's it's that it's not like when you go from 17
and a half to like 18.1.
I just don't think morally the the compass moves very much. Legally
it moves a and I'm fine with it being there legally. It's just
morally it doesn't actually shift that much. It was already weird
as [__] for you to be going for an 18-year-old, right?
That's the problem. >> Well, I mean, to be fair, it was
19 before and it is a little bit different. A 19 versus a 17.
Just just >> It is It is different. It is like more
>> It It really doesn't like um I I don't see how this
moves you over the line or anything like that. It's just
>> I'm going to be the good guy and be the good guy for
optics. I disagree with these two, you know? Yeah. I'm actually
crying actually. Like, it hurt me personally that actually go
17. Like that's how upset I am. >> And he cares for all
girls. Okay. >> Don't want to be next to these guys. You
>> it was creepy
already. Um it is creepier. It is obviously creepier to go for
somebody who's in high school versus somebody who's uh graduated
high school.
>> why is Kenny guys but pro
>> Kenny loves Li. Kenny loves Lolly. >> Kenny loves
the Kenning
me. You know I'm black, right? Lynch me,
Uh-huh. Okay. >> You get to use that defense once. You
get to use that that defense once. Okay. Saved. Didn't it save
Spinal BJ one >> The black the black defense.
>> You guys are just lynching me. I I think it's a one
time get out of jail free card. No.
>> Uh maybe. >> No, I think it's I I think I can
spam >> That's just as bad as But um it is a bit >> Aiden
is a little bit Here's sus for you. Here's sus for you. >> Um
I Dude. Yeah, exactly. No. Um, obviously texting this person
where when there's no age verification. Like it is it is a reckless
abandon is like uh totally reckless behavior. Yes. Um shows that
he didn't care. He like I don't think Destiny cared if he [__]
17-year-old. I don't think give right. He had the plausible deniability.
That's all there that's all he needed. Um but who like I don't
know. >> Like I that's all loaded into my mental model
of the guy already. So I just can't get like any more upset about
If I had the opportunity to get with a 17-year-old right now,
I would I would >> was age consult.
>> I don't >> Oh, spudg. Yeah. The idea that she
might have been underage and he like kind of checked and Yeah,
absolutely. Yeah. Absolutely. The recklessness, the the reckless
behavior and knowing that he might get in trouble for it and
have some like kind of uh plausible deniability. Yeah, it absolutely
all works in there. Yeah. >> 17. Did you get Christina
>> That's all like my personal read though. I don't think
you can really like prove I I think that's like more difficult
to prove out. This just like my personal read. That's like how
I would that's how I would try to predict his like future behavior
essentially, right?
So >> this guy's a psycho, dude. He broke >> Hold
on. I just missed that. I just missed that. >> I don't
um Did you get Christina?
>> The This guy's a psycho, dude. He broke a bitch's nose
and his friend was recounting the story to me and he got he tried
to run away because he got embarrassed after breaking her nose
and >> embarrassed scared >> he tripped while he
was running this fat ass trip while he was running away and then
he got tracked down guys to the the bus stop cuz his friend ratted
him out and they beat the [__] out of him. I am not
kidding. >> That was all true. Yeah,
>> but that was a different >> You saw that story
on stream. I'm pretty >> Aiden it's child. I don't think
it should be. >> Um, thanks.
>> Why is he just suddenly arguing that
17 shouldn't be child?
>> Aiden said to said that people shouldn't be porn until
like five of them. I
>> I do think it's weird when there's like a big disconnect
between the age of consent and the the CP laws.
But I like I I think there's something weird there that you could
like somebody but not record it. But it's I don't know.
>> Is it though federally? Aren't they both like federal
laws? If both of 18, it's like the >> I think so. Yeah.
>> Of the state. You blame the 10th
>> But like I think I think you shouldn't have that broadly.
So probably if you're below 18, I wouldn't be shocked if I think
I think it would just be better to only have the Romeo and Juliet
exceptions for people who are minors. Like that would be Yeah,
I don't see any reason to have something more than that.
I just think probably you move the age of consent up to 18 or
sorry like some age with Romeo and Juliet exceptions. Yeah, I
think think 18
with like Romeo and Juliet exceptions going younger than >> No,
I think up to 20. I think up to 30 should be because only 30-year-olds
are hot. Really? I need you to run. That's epic. No age 19. I
need you to run. That's me. Me when I'm running away after hitting
a woman because uh Barry hits me because he thought I hit the
That's epic. That's epic. I actually so my like moral system
is not based on the law. I respect the law. >> Very brave.
>> But what I think is wrong and right is not based on
the law. Problem. >> I I just listen I just um I think
there is something to be said. >> I don't think they should
be arrested over possession of marijuana in Texas. Okay. It's
illegal. I don't think it's immoral. Right. >> I It's I
don't listen. I feel like um >> Why doesn't he just stick
to that argument when he wants to like separate morality from
legality? Just stick to weed, bro. Now, you don't have to talk
about age of consent or child porn. All right, come on. Come
on, Aiden. >> A sliding scale where obviously see of a
17-year-old versus a child or like, you know, a 10-year-old,
whatever. Obviously, the 17-year-old is as bad. Um, but I do
think there is something to be said about like having these like
naive people, these underage people have like lived in their
world and going after them and getting them to do these list
of things. You know, he was like paying this person or produced
particular types of news as well. >> I guess I'm a little
biased here cuz like I'm in DMs right now with multiple >> Yeah,
I saw those, but I didn't look at them. Goodness. >> Got
him. >> So, you're not You never engage when I make a points,
man. It's so annoying.
>> Why is this guy such a hypocrite? >> The whole
spiel and now you're just going to get chats.
>> No, Spinal is into like little prepubescent children.
I like 17-year-old adults.
>> Just let me know you have CP videos saved to your computer.
You knew it was alleged that you were not. You still have them.
Do you see how this is? So, now I've confirmed that this guy
has child on his computer. in my eight years of reaching out
to people over allegations. I've never had anyone admit that
to me. The last message he sent me was one. I don't even know
100% of her age was legitimately less than 18 when these were
taken. So basically, he's not 100% sure if he has child on his
computer. He's just n. >> Who the [__] are
those guys? Um, you don't need to know who this guy is. Uh, Purple
Perry Gaming on YouTube.
perry gaming. Like parries and sword Perry. Okay. >> 99%
sure. Got it. For context, I was 17 less than 3 years ago, so
I have a little perspective.
>> Two, I'm pretty sure I have an obligation to preserve
stuff related to my court case. I've talked about it with my
lawyer already, specifically with regards to the Rose stuff.
So, he went from I don't know if I could delete this to my lawyer
says it's totally fine to keep. I don't know the law, but the
idea that his lawyer would tell him to >> What' he say?
>> You think he told his lawyer that Rose is probably 17?
>> Potentially. I don't think a law his lawyer though I
think this is like an outright lie. Obviously, I don't think
his lawyer would ever advise him to like store that. >> That's
information. Yeah. Yeah, that's like prescription. And then the
fact that he would like admit that is even more like insane.
>> I think his lawyer told him if Willie Mack asks you,
you have to send him a VLC screen crop of the sea sound. I think
his lawyer said that. I'm pretty >> when I was 22, 19 was
looking weird. And >> all right, that's Listen, >> what
is >> this? Just who who's ever possessed to like go into
YouTube chats and just like openly lie like this?
>> When I was playing
person in the world. Actually, I I've never been attracted to
anyone that's even like remotely close to 18. I actually like
I think probably 20 25 is when women stop being attractive,
>> Why? Just it's enough to just shut the [__]
up. Okay, it's enough.
>> What is wrong with you? >> I like from a romantic
point of view, I >> They're young. Their ass is right when
they're 19. It's like big and succulent. Okay, so
>> is the gayest Aiden is the gayest person I've ever seen
in my life. >> Wait, J's actually seeing right now. This
guy has more women in his chat and he's saying all this. How
do you feel, >> Yeah, that's because he's gay. Like, openly
openly, transparently gay. >> That was the gayest thing
I've ever
>> That was crazy. What do you mean 19 is looking weird?
>> You have to go into the box. You have to look up. You
have to wipe away all the feces you have under your bottom lip.
>> I'm saying you eat ass and all the feces get stored
in your bottom lip.
>> No. Don't Don't let Aiden get away with the Nick Fentes
thing of, "Oh, I'm actually just a because I have no desire for
women." Okay. Don't let him do that. Don't let him do it. Not
even his bit >> to hold on to CP. Miss Dona. Oh, sorry.
>> Cuz you were doing these in batches. >> Yes. I
am into people like 3 years younger than me. I'm basically a
>> I mean into psycho attraction and romantic attraction.
I don't know. I feel like at the point where you're like with
somebody. >> Okay, disavow. Lumpy, go lower. Have you seen
the 15? Okay, it's disavow. >> I do think there's something
to be said though, right? Like it's not just that you're like
being
innocent.
>> Lumpy's innocent. That's a Destiny
>> He said go lower than the 15year-olds are putting out
these days
>> when they're 17. Like Destiny over months, over years
in fact, was like texting with this person talking about their
fancies. Not just their fantasies. Destiny was talking with the
Trolls person. I believe when they were still 17. Oh, I could
be wrong about that. About this [__] divorce with
Molina, right? So, I feel like this goes beyond just a sexual
attraction like Destiny's like romantically engaging with this
like kid or whatever, which I think >> Sure. Sure. I think
it's odd. I think I think the slam dunk though would be definitive
proof he knew she was 17. >> Um, I think it's beyond reasonable
doubt at this point. Well, no, actually >> I think we need
>> How long was Destiny messaging with Rose? Um, like a
year,
I think. I think he linked at some point his logs where it ends
and then in ohc 2024 he re
but it's April 1st 2022 when she registers the account and then
sometime between April 1st and like April 6th to 7th 8th somewhere
in there when they
talk on Twitter and then they go to
>> we need her under the DMs >> with Destiny is just
so reckless. >> I do believe it's April 1st when the Twitter
account is created. April 9th when when he sends the video Pixie
to her. So that is like such an egregious lie to me that he put
in court filings that he like had met this person or sorry that
he put in Discord to Pixie. Like I knew this person. I trusted
them. I talked to him on the phone multiple times. No, you've
known them for like seven days.
Like that is an egregious lie.
That's >> actually I don't even know if we need her into
the DMs cuz if she did send him like a school ID or something,
why would he not be saying that right now? >> Yeah, that's
what I'm saying. So, I think it's beyond reasonable doubt that
he doesn't know, right? Like the fact that Destiny's sending
it, right? There's no way if he didn't have a he didn't take
a picture and he isn't [__] sharing. That's bad.
>> He's got to share the CP before he sends the ID. Are
you kidding me? No. >> Yeah, he's probably in a fear.
>> it's pretty bad. >> But that's the issue is like
this like attraction attraction and he's like, you know, doing
this like weird roleplay stuff and he's like being reckless about
it with these people who are like more vulnerable than, you know,
adult. Uh, that's what I think. Harry, opinions on pyroynical
stuff? I I don't know anything about that. I trust everything
Toastify says though. You should watch his videos. He is Indian
though. So maybe I shouldn't say that cuz maybe Maltese people
will be upset that I'm saying that like Indian people >> there's
a lot of Indians here. They're very hard. >> Maybe like
I should appeal to the right to be multis people. Whatever. Just
don't pause the video for
You've a civil case just doesn't seem likely to me. I don't know.
Law tube can figure that out. Three. If something were to come
out of this, I don't know if I'd want to wipe everything and
not have something to turn over to the authorities if hypothetically
whenever a >> The other thing too is how would having video
like how would h minus the fact that it might be se like >> Yeah,
that's a good point Missy that he wouldn't have said like oh
I got the ID. He didn't say that and I I think he never checked
explicitly. I sorry I know he never checked explicitly.
I I think those Twitter DMs are real. I there's just no way to
prove it, right? like I I can't, you know, do analysis with those
kept in mind, but they seem to be backed up by most of the other
facts around, including,
and I don't know what you guys think about this, but the fact
that Tom Foolery, who's gotten multiple corrections from Destiny
on what the evidence is, and Counterpoints, who's gotten corrections
from Destiny on what the evidence is, both of them treat those
DMs like they're real. Like I understand they're both and they
might do that anyway, but I would think that Desi would correct
them to be honest with you. And the lack of correction is a little
interesting to me. >> A child like
>> But what would what would like how would that benefit
his case?
your honor, clearly I wasn't that attracted to Pixie. Look at
all these hot images this 17-year-old me. How could I care about
this pixie d? That would be the argument. >> Yeah. Like
I just I don't want this lawyer. Like, do you think it's just
the case he's avoiding deleting it because he still wants to
jerk to it? Like, >> obviously. Obviously. >> That's
crazy, Don. Bro, that's nuts. >> Well, don't creators about
to give a hypothetical. You know, you're about to hear some >> Oh,
true. Tom was saying they were photoshopped. I thought Tom ran
with them. Tom was saying something out of them the other day
that I saw. I don't know why he was, but you're right. That Tom
Tom was trying to say that the uh the color offset was was disproving
them, but I could have sworn he was using them to like talk about
stuff. some weird [__] If hypothetically her boyfriend
or what? >> Oh, did you just see your avatar update, >> Oh,
what?
>> No, you're laughing at something else. >> I don't
know. Make me look like Oh, no. He said that Tom Tom like disagreed
because of color color distortion. I'm like, this guy some kind
of artist now.
>> Uh, it's like you zoom in, there's like a color offset.
Weird. Whatever was >> multiple anti-desty people were
saying they were photoshopped confidently.
Um, well, they there's there's like maybe some reason to believe
they're photoshopped. Like apparently there's some color offset,
but it's like I would expect Ashley to come out and like outright
say, "No, those DMs are fake." Personally, I have no idea why
he
actually trafficking her or getting her to other dudes on video
for him. And if there was ever some kind of investigation into
that, am I hurting the chain? >> This is the other thing
he does too that I know. It's like I'll say he's very he's good
at narrative control. The guy's good at narrative control. What
he does is there is another obvious like bad person in the situation.
I think Solo is a bad guy. I think Solo is just as bad if not
worse than Destiny, right? He's the guy that >> Solo uh
actually this is this might be an example of Destiny being pretty
good at narrative control because the fact that we need to remember
here is that there is almost no definitive proof that Solo is
her boyfriend. In fact, there may be zero definitive proof that
Solo is her boyfriend. We've run with that assumption because
it tends to make the most sense. It's most believable. It's what
I would probably lean towards believing, but there is no actual
solid proof that Solo is her boyfriend. A's issue is the leak
nudes and Solo did
Um, okay. You could say Solo's worse than Destiny for doing the
leak.
Sure. But I'm saying like Destiny's trying to say, oh, this is
somebody who's done like uh who's trafficked her and like recorded
her other dudes and it's like there's no proof that that's the
same person. There just isn't. Destiny also said he was a hacker.
Well, Destiny said that he got hacked when those things got released,
but that's like kind of just in the moment lying. >> Didn't
Solo delete Rose's dudes from her into the DMs they leaked? I
don't know if he did. >> I leaked the videos, right? >> Don't
care. >> If he did, then why does why why are we saying
that Destiny has ceased Sam if they're all deleted on that end
>> alleged? No, no, I know you don't care, but I'm saying
he'll take the fact for him to like leave. No, but what Destiny
will do is he'll take this other bad person in the situation
to make himself look like the victim or or like this is the bad
guy you should be focusing on. >> It's like all the CP
that's solo
>> Sure, they might have removed Rose's leaks. Sure. But
that could also be because he believes they're um like CP, right?
But that that would be another good indication that if he believed
they were CP, that might be why he didn't want to, you know,
himself post them onto Kiwi Farms.
>> Well, yeah. I'm fine with saying Solo is just as bad,
if not worse, than Destiny, but the difference is Solo doesn't
have as much like influence uh and like power as Destiny. So,
obviously, we're going to be way more focused on him. >> Um
yeah, I'd say he is around. He's he's done pretty bad stuff.
And I mean, but the stuff Destiny says about him, the >> The
answer to this is just that like we know who Destiny is. We don't
know who Solo is. I can't do anything. I can't talk about Solo,
right? Like I there's no no reason like Destiny is somebody.
Yes. with influence with a platform. I can talk about the bad
things Destiny's done. I can criticize Destiny. Criticizing Solo
means nothing.
Like, if you think that's a valid argument, oh, why aren't you
mad about Solo? Then you could also just go, uh, there are like
a bunch of actual in America. Why don't you open up some child
predator list and start criticizing those people? Like, yeah,
those people don't have big platforms. Those people aren't like
somebody I've associated with personally. It's like not the same
at >> There's no evidence for it's specifically the leaking.
>> No, I mean, yeah, immigrants to not like solo leaked
that to >> Kiwi. Yeah, exactly. That's the bad part. But
Destiny, to be clear, makes arguments about how he's like a sex.
I don't think there's any. >> Yeah. No, I'm not buying.
But I'm saying I'm saying like this guy gave those videos to
the entire internet. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Like that's pretty of looking into him by deleting all of this
>> Aiden is I'm not a like you guys are so by this Destiny
guy that like any like I don't align with like the spicy chat.
>> He like literally can't stop himself from smiling while
he does the uh the contrarian thing for Destiny like every time.
It's very funny. He just actually can't stop himself from smiling.
He's like so happy when people can go, "Oh, you just agree with
Destiny,
right?" He He's like so happy. He's so happy. >> Matters
on this. Like I'm not like here thinking of Destiny all day.
I'm not being deprogrammed cuz there's no programming to begin
with. This guy could drop dead tomorrow. I wouldn't >> First
day in multiverse is now you should have seen it. Guys, >> I
wouldn't care. I just I just think we have a rock solid point
here. I'm not going to sit here and pretend like someone's opinion
over the 17-year-old.
No, it's over for you. >> I'm sorry. I just can't. I can't
do it. >> Yeah, but tomorrow you're going to be on my stream
wearing a [__] watch with you. It's going to be epic.
>> I guess if >> Are they doing another stream together?
Are they actually going to do another stream? Was that the plan?
Does anyone know these were these things planned?
>> I'd watch another stream.
I also don't know if I'm going to make it through this Willie
video. How long do they got? Oh, no. I'm going to make it through.
>> He's 33 at the time of these and 35 now
>> Yeah. I mean, maybe I'd have to get older to to realize
how bad it is. >> You do? Yeah.
>> It's just like cuz I don't view myself as like that
different from 17-year-olds. Like >> the attraction point
is like whatever. Obviously, you shouldn't do it cuz it's illegal
and you know the the paradise, but mostly for me it's like the
fact that he's flirting with this person with them talking about
personal stuff for >> Dude, the the guy who makes the AI
avatars just made Aiden look like a Chad when he This is not
what Aiden looks like. But it's good. This is a good generation
for Aiden. Okay. This is a good generation.
Never mind. He lost. >> Never mind.
AI guy won. Boom. >> This is insane to That's the insane
part to me. >> Um, it grows. I mean, it's not as bad, I
think, as like the sharing of our >> I I think this is
just a thing where I need to like get a bit older to like fully
understand. >> Well, you have to get, you know, wiser.
So, just you get >> Well, I'm wiser, but it's I don't view
17-year-olds as kids. Like, I don't view >> You're going
to get older, but because you're going to be like a manchild
streaming, it's not going to matter. >> A manchild streaming.
You're a fat short little land whale who the only two dates he's
had have been failures. Your friends caught you and laughed at
you. You assaulted a woman and got beat up by four Slavic guys.
And now you scream about Aerodite stuttering at 3 a.m. for $40
a night. I mean, you might as well become a dress up. You might
as well put on a wig, put on some lipstick, put on a dress, and
become a cam girl. I'll pimp you out, you little [__]
>> No, not you, though. You're too much of a twink.
It's like a fem daunting, you know. Anyway, all of those things
are adult. Are you saying kids should be >> Oh, so now
the reason he's keeping the CP is because >> I'm sorry.
When every time Aiden hits play while Perry is talking in the
same room as him, Aiden lost. Okay. That he's just trying to
hit play and like move on and stop Perry from responding. That's
you. You lost, Aiden. You lost every single time.
>> A hypothetical criminal case that he is not pursuing
at all. >> You're just like pathetic. I like have a hard
time viewing you as a human being. >> Okay, maybe these
reasons are >> 80 poo check art.
Oh, I guess it's in your Discord. I think that was it. Yeah.
>> What the
This is disgusting, man. >> What even is this? >> Who
Who drew this? I need to ban them. Who drew this? >> Looks
like Show it now. >> It doesn't.
>> Show it to me. >> You're getting banned. Whoever
the This is disgusting, dude.
What the
>> Is that poor ter? What the hell? Like you have to like
I think to some extent this is as bad as what Destiny >> Why
is Porter Beller the child? Can somebody explain to me why Porter
Beller is the child here? Do we do we know why Porter Bellar
is the child? We have any idea? Kind of lost
because he is
all right. >> He did in my mind drawing something like
>> Are legally sound advice that came from his lawyer.
Maybe he's lying and just saying anything to make it sound better
to me. I don't know. I'm not a lawyer. I just know this guy's
admitting to having CP in my DMs. 60 GB according to him. Seriously,
how does he know the amount if he doesn't have it? Also, how
does her boyfriend being in the wrong somehow make Destiny in
the right? >> That's a good point. >> It makes no
sense. >> It's like an obvious point. It's like he's making
very obvious points that like anyone could [__] include
>> the 60 GB. It's not actually the C just apparently like
they said that they had 60 GB just as a minor. >> No, I'm
saying I'm saying the good point would be the boyfriend. Yes,
that's what I'm saying is a good point, right? Cuz I just made
that same point a few moments >> Yeah, I know you're self
glazing. I >> No, I'm not self I'm saying that is a good
point, right? >> Yeah. And so you're self. >> The
problem is these are very easy things to conclude. Like just
as easy as like realizing like the narrative control and like
manipulation, distortion of events Destiny was engaging in over
the last couple of months. Well, well before the last couple
months obviously, but most notably over the LA like last couple
months. And it's like I just don't care. And I don't care. I
honestly don't care that Willie like you did the bare minimum.
Congrats. People are using this as though it's some immense dub.
Like it's the bare [__] minimum if you know or believe
that somebody's in possession of seam to report them to authorities.
That doesn't change the fact that you were you only jumped off
the ship now. We're sweeping for this guy for months. made a
damaging, blatantly false claim to which was more than likely
a knowing lie and have yet to retract it. It's too late. L bro,
>> knowing lie provided directly to you by >> You're
going down with the ship. >> Who's pretending it's a dub?
>> Do I need to? Yeah, >> you know the answer. >> For
all he knows, her boyfriend could have been >> and that's
it.
>> So, not Nick or who else is? >> Nick might be.
Nick might be. I'd have to see the Discord link. >> Who
else is doing it? Oh, okay. I wouldn't be surprised. >> All
right. >> It's like a dub in like the extent like >> Oh,
you didn't inter that child. That's >> like not littering
would be a like >> 17 as well. Dude, you were 33. I reported
this to the police and recorded my interactions and calls with
the >> William, how you doing as officer? >> Have
you? >> Hello. Nice to uh speak with you again. >> Great
question. >> You had uh screenshots or copies of the >> Yes.
of when you guys spoke about having child porn and all that.
>> Yeah. I also sent him my DMs with Destiny. I >> when
you guys spoke about having >> Don't know if anything will
come from this. I don't like leaking DMs. Is me respecting what
creators want on and off the record. >> I mean, you could
say the reactions this put together. Okay. I like the reactions
to this. That's cool. >> Allows me to talk to all sides
of the situation builds trust. >> Look, I will say this.
The good thing here is I believe the legal consequences
should have come after the non-conentual sharing of images. But
if this is what does him in and he gets a harsh punishment over
this, I think it's like welld deserved but mostly for the previous
crime that he's not being charged on. >> Good job, man.
>> But the creator and also >> he did it. You figured
it out. >> So allows me to get follow-up statements for
when the drama develops. But when you tell me, >> okay,
Lumpy Willie says we got to go to 204. God damn it. that you're
in possession of and going to remain in possession of CP that
confidentiality is over. I shouldn't even need to say that. If
Destiny ends up being legally in the right to keep it, then fair
enough. If he ends up getting charged, then I'm glad I did something.
I'm just trying to do the right thing in a situation I've never
been in before.
>> Can you imagine Destiny got catfished
and Rose is actually some fat like 300 lb like 40-year-old trailer
park trash that's like posing as a 17 a 17-year-old pretending
to be 19 online. It works on you. I saw you d up to her leaked
images
>> When Barry was here, you were like, "Hey, excuse me,
Barry. Excuse me, Barry." And you went to this room and you pulled
up the kiwi ponds of Rose and you pulled your circumcised calls
and you started brains. >> Very believable story that definitely
>> What I'm saying? So, you go catch fish, too. How does
that feel?
>> Now, apparently,
this is something I really want to go over and this is a segment
I'm excited to do. So, if you go and interrupt it. I'm
part of the segments. What do you >> I'm going to start.
Can I do I have just like permission to start punching you and
interrupt me? >> Well, I don't care about your
>> Starbase and Spinal in chat. Double the Are they both
here? Do you guys want to call in? >> Let's get to a two
two. >> Yeah, let's get this going, guys. >> I'm
going to interrupt the whole time.
>> What leads up to uh Perry getting almost kicked out
of the room. Let's check. >> Boring. And I really hated
it >> cuz it was just like I had to take a bus super early.
go there, spend the whole day, go back home. I hated it. So,
I tried to change my role and um it was something like you can
apply for it and it's a form that you fill out and then they're
going to give you something else completely random. You have
no idea. >> Then get out. >> I want to get out. I
want you to change the thing. >> I mean like you have to
show this whole thing. Just show the highlights. >> Is
your friend from South Italy? He's not. We're in Malta.
>> He's Maltese. >> It's like, oh, she's evil cuz
she joined the mandatory mily service. She's going >> That's
not the crit. Oh, now you're just making arguments. Now you're
just making sure to actually have a conversation. So gay that
you're like Oh, it's actually different from tax. You didn't
explain why, by the way. He didn't explain why it was different
from like paying taxes. >> Wait, wait. Do you not realize
>> it's more direct because the country is >> Yes.
But when you're assessing >> like forced labor, >> when
you're assessing someone's capability to do moral bad, obviously
obviously an indirect contribution where you don't necessarily
know that you're contributing to a moral bad is going to have
like a less damaging uh assessment of the person themselves as
opposed to something direct where you know what's going on and
still decide to participate. Right. >> Depend on how they
feel about what they're doing.
>> Yes. But if they feel as though the annexation of sovereign
territory is just like justified. >> So you should criticize
that statement, not the >> That's what I'm That's what
I'm doing. >> No, you're saying that her being in it. You're
saying that her just doing the military service is the >> That's
what we're That's literally what we're talking about. >> Yeah.
And I'm saying that's stupid to say that just her doing the mandatory
military service is >> I'm not criticizing that. I'm criticizing
her volunteer
to part. I literally said that's not even the point. You need
to criticize participation.
That's a common point of criticism and there is partial truth
to it, but that's not the point you need to grasp to when she
voluntarily participated in a raid in the illegally occupied
West Bank.
>> like I agree that the um it's not even just her persuading
raid. It's her the way she talks about it and it's like clear
she doesn't feel any issue with it and then she wants to pretend
that she's like neutral about stuff. Uh but she didn't persevere.
She didn't like shoot >> Get out. >> Oh, okay. You
sure? >> Yeah, I'm sure. Get out. >> All right, fine.
Let me just take this.
You put on the BRB screen. >> No, get out. >> Going
to take a while. This means you're running, by the way. >> Sit
down.
>> What? Okay. How am I going to get out? Sit down. >> Sit
down. >> You're just like messing with me. This is like
[__] >> Take a seat.
>> Are you done? >> Can you plug it in? >> No,
you plug it in. >> But you told me to plug it out. >> Well,
plug it back in. >> No, but no, cuz you were like a dick.
You were like >> plug it in. >> I don't [__]
Are you [__] kidding? >> Is this like how it
went when you punched her in the face? It was like pick up the
cigarette. You're like >> I'm not I'm not picking up the
cigarette. And then you like punch her. I'm not going to pick
up this though. You told me to unplug it. So you're plug it back
in. This was >> Yeah. It's like uh it's like a really cringe
like
>> you ever see like the red pill guys who aren't like
Andrew Tater Myin and they're like so cringe in the way they're
so overt trying to assert dominance over women and [__]
This is like exactly what I'm watching for Aiden. It's uh it's
not cool. It's not very funny. Well, you beat you. You're such
a [__] [__] by the way, for bringing
that up. God, you're so bad fate. You like lost the debates.
>> You literally looked through my computer when I stepped
out of the room. >> Oh, so that means you can be bad fates.
That's what that means. >> Can you unban um unmelt ape
gamer from Icy Chat? >> No, the guy [__] leaked
messages. >> Yeah, so what? You leak messages all the time.
You leaked our [__] with Barry. >> Sorry. There's
something so funny about him going, "You leak messages all the
time." when uh
uh I'm sorry that is very funny. >> Barry is so much cooler
than you. >> Ooh. What is Parapon and Parry DMing right
now? That's the question. >> They made fun of you.
They called you a a drunkard.
>> A drunkard?
>> Get out.
>> You're going to do this again? You're going to kick
me out again? >> Perry lost this one. >> Why? You
going to plug it back in or >> Plug it in. M's kind of
like a wine ant sometimes. I get why he's got an all female viewership.
Okay. They see themselves in him. All right. He gets a couple
drinks going and then he's just he's like a
you know he's a total pill and he gets a couple drinks going.
Okay.
>> No, you told me to unplug it. >> So, plug it back
in. >> I changed my mind. >> Yeah. Then you fix it.
You're going to change your mind. >> Just like plug it
in.
>> but Aiden can't
this. >> Hey, it's yours. Going to go down. All >> stand
for him.
we did. >> Oh, wait. No, no, no. He only He only hit play
without actually plugging the
>> You're right. Wait, I have to plug it >> Oh, you're
so >> I'm not plugging it in. I'm not plugging it in, bro.
Why am I even wearing these [__] headphones, Dude?
>> I'm not plugging it in. >> It's over. It's actually
over for you. You know that? >> It's not happening. >> Hey,
Aiden, set up right now. Sit down right now. Set up right. >> Yeah,
just pull up your DMs with Nicholas D. We can talk about those.
You'll need a video for you to reveal that there was the Oreo
X par X. Sorry, X8 of the apps. You need a video for that. So,
>> can you just plug it in?
>> Well, I just unplugged the second mod. Okay. Give me
your hand. >> You unplug something else. >> Give
me your hand. >> No.
If you're going to be gay about
disaster, this is a disaster. >> Give me Give me your hand.
Give me my You're going to like [__] I don't
>> No. Put out your hand. >> Put out your hand. >> No.
Put out your hand. >> Put out your hand. >> Put out
your hand. >> I'm just going to put that right there. Just
going to grab that. Move it.
>> So, are we just going to like sit here?
look at the Look at the unfiltered joy on Aiden's face. >> It's
a class screen.
>> Just going to grab that. Move it. >> I'm moving
that. >> So, are we just going to like sit here now? on
the stream.
>> Yeah, cuz you just >> he he kind of It's weird
how his natural reaction when he's happy is to rub his hands
together. Okay, that's
>> got epigenetic memories of favorable business dealings.
Okay, let's go. >> Yeah, bro. You told me to unplug it.
I
>> I said disavow.
>> Why would you disavow? >> Plug it back in. Are
you [__] kidding >> Just Just plug it back
in. >> no, you plug it back in. >> Plug it back in.
See, this is what happens when an unstoppable force meets meets
an immobile object. >> You're very movable. You're going
to pick it up back in. And really, I'm Listen, your it's your
dream. >> I'm not plugging it back in. >> All right.
>> Of the head of the >> You know what we can do
instead? >> We could pull up to your
>> What is your obsession? You already read those cuz you
went through my computer. >> I just I just looked at them.
Really? I didn't read them. >> Honestly, you should plug
it in over >> Is that okay? I don't know what that >> You
should over just like doing that. You should feel so ashamed.
You should plug it back in. >> Unplug this over there.
>> There's like a I don't know the
So, there was a >> You're just going to guess what she's
>> like a brigade, I guess, that's in charge of the on
speaker >> and that brigade has like a main >> So,
I was his secretary. >> I don't think Aiden could handle
Perry and Duckbringer at the same time. Okay. That would be that
would be crazy. >> You were right below the big boy. >> So,
it was nice.
Um, it was more just destroy just more rewarding cuz you're put
in this weird situation where you're like you don't you're away
from your house. >> All right. Where's the raiderala part?
This is boring. >> And um so I always saw them preparing
for it and leaving.
>> guys. That's it for the stream tonight. I'm headed to
bed. Thank you everybody for being here. I'm going to host Ieko.
Okay, I live. We're going to host Ieko. Go say hi to Ieko. I'm
going to send you over there. And I am headed to bed. I'll be
back tomorrow.
W stream. Uh I think we didn't even watch the AB preach video.
I have no idea if I'll watch it tomorrow. Um maybe. What else?
Tomorrow I could probably go over the Raja Jackson stuff tomorrow
as well.
Possibly. Uh depending on what's out, depending on what's happening.
Maybe check out the French streamer that died. The French kick
streamer that died. Okay, so send you guys over to Ieko. Have
a good time and I'll be back tomorrow. Have a good night, guys.
See